OF A GOOD AFTERNOON AND
WELCOME TODAY'S HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY TO ME I'M REVENUE
AND TAXATION TO THE PANDEMIC
WE ARE CONTINUING TO PRACTICE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON WE ARE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT MASKING MORNING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY
ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN
THE ROOM OR AT THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY IF ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN A BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I WOULD ASK THAT THE
DISTANCING A SERVER AFTERNOON
AND TODAY'S HERE OF THIS- TO ME
I'M ATTACK TO THE PANDA WE ARE
CAN TO PRACTICE FOR DISK HERE
IN THE HERE ROOM THROUGHOUT THE
BUILDING SO ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMB NUMBER PEOPLE WATCH
EMERGENCY IN THE HEARING IN PER.
WE ARE ALSO A THAT MASKING MORE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE ME TO BY
ALL MEMBERS OF PUBLIC WEATHER
HERE IN THE ARE AT THE VIDEO
SITE IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A WITH
PROVIDE FOR YOU WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESSED
TODAY OF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING A REAL WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN A BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH. THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE HEARING ROOM
INCLUDING LIMITING. LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. WE WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATE TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALLING
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AN ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOUR. TWO ZERO TWO. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR- TV SCREEN. IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AS WE ONLY
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF BILLS.
ON TODAY'S AGENDA. IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE. ELIMINATE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE THIS
INCLUDES MEETING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCASTS AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. IF YOU. ARE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATE A PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO NINE EIGHT AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO HELP. I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO
THE POSITION LETTER. PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. NOW
THEY TO GO OR IF YOU. HOUSE CAN
BE ANNOUNCED. FOR THE- BEING
TAKEN UP TO WILL TO NO MORE
THAN TWO. WITNESSES AND TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OR WITH CONCERN. THESE
WITNESSES WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
EACH PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY
ALL SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES SHOULD
STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY. WE ALSO HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CREE WILL BE
PLACING ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES
FOR TODAY'S HEARING ONLY. HOW
MANY DO. WELL WE HAVE OKAY MISS
HIGHLY COULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL BURKE HERE BURKE HERE
WHEN HERE. GRAYSON LEVINE WE
ALL CREATE HERE MORE. EACH
NORRIS. PETRIE-NORRIS HERE HER
HERE HER CARE RIVAS WE'VE YEARS
ARE. WITHOUT A MEMORY WAS WHEN
I YOU'RE READY. YOU AFTERNOON.
I KNOW BACK WITH A OF YOU WOULD
HAVE- I KNOW WHICH SHOULD BE ON.
WITH LIKE IT'S ON. THE NUMBER.
RIGHT MY TECHNICIAN. YEAH.
ACTIONS WITH ALL OF YOU- AND
STAKEHOLDERS I HAVE AMENDED AB
SEVENTY ONE TO REMOVE
REFERENCES TO HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT REMOVE THE
CORPORATE TAX AND MAKE
ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS- THANKS TO THE
ASSISTANCE FROM THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD. AB SEVENTY ONE
ESTABLISHES THE BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME ACT AND CREATES
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER AN
ONGOING SOURCE OF STATE FUNDING
FOR LONG TERM SOLUTIONS TO
HOMELESSNESS. SPECIFICALLY AB
SEVENTY ONE COULD GENERATE UP
TO ONE BILLION ANNUALLY BY
CONFORMING STATE TAX LAWS TO
FEDERAL LAW. ADDITIONALLY THIS
MEASURE HOLD GOVERNMENTS
ACCOUNTABLE AND INCORPORATES
SIGNIFICANT TRANSPARENCY
MEASURES TO ENSURE EVERY DOLLAR
IS USED EFFECTIVELY OUR STATE
IS FACING AN UNPRECEDENTED
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS THAT IS ON
ON THE VERGE OF BECOMING A FULL
BLOWN CATASTROPHE DUE TO THE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF COVE IN
NINETEEN. DESPITE BEING THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD ONE IN FOUR AMERICANS IS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
OR ONE IN FOUR RESIDING
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THAT
MEANS THAT OVER A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING CHILDREN. OUR IN
HOUSE ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT.
THOUSANDS MORE ARE ON THE BRINK
OF HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE OF THIS
PANDEMIC. IT'S TIME THAT WE
CHANGE OUR APPROACH AND GIVE
CALIFORNIA A FIGHTING CHANCE TO
REVERSE HOMELESSNESS. THE
ONGOING INVESTMENTS PROPOSED BY
THIS BILL COULD MEAN TWENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND PEOPLE A YEAR
THAT ARE ON THE BRINK OF
HOMELESSNESS WOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE APARTMENTS OR
RENTAL ASSISTANCE. TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN FAMILIES A
YEAR WHAT ACCESS SAFE SHELTER
WHILE THEY LOOK FOR PERMANENT
HOUSING. FORTY THREE THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS WOULD BE ABLE TO
MOVE INTO PERMANENT HOUSING.
AND OVER FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
COULD RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
SERVICES SUCH AS EMPLOYMENT
SUPPORT WITHIN THE FIRST YEAR
OF THE BILL BEING SIGNED INTO
LAW. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT FUNDING ALONE WILL
NOT SOLVE OUR HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS WHICH IS WHY I'M ALSO
OFFERING AB TWELVE TWENTY WHICH
IS REVAMPING OUR CURRENT
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE. I'M
HONORED THAT THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BI PARTISAN SUPPORT
LAST YEAR AND I'M WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THAT
LEGISLATION THIS YEAR. WITH
GOVERNANCE REFORM AND CREATING
AN ONGOING FUNDING SOURCE WE
CAN BOTH READ REDUCE
BUREAUCRACY OF THE EXISTING
PROCESS AND PROVIDE OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH A STABLE
FUNDING SOURCE. AND ONGOING
FUNDING SOURCE GIVES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DESPERATELY NEEDED
STRUCTURE AND CONFIDENCE TO
IMPLEMENT RESPONSE PLANS AND
PROGRAMS THAT COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS. TODAY I'M HONORED
TO HAVE WITH ME THE AUTHOR OF
LEGISLATION THAT CREATED THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL OR FORMER
SENATE COLLEAGUE AND SENATE
BUDGET CHAIR AND NOW L. A.
COUNTY SUPERVISOR HOLLY
MITCHELL. ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE
COUNCIL MEMBER RIDLEY THOMAS
WHO HAS BEEN AN INCREDIBLE
ADVOCATE IN LOS ANGELES AND
STATEWIDE AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE ON
HOMELESSNESS. UP IT ALSO HERE
TO SUPPORT- THE BILL.
ADDITIONALLY I HAVE PROFESSOR
DARIEN SHANK SEE PROFESSOR OF
LAW AT THE UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF
LAW AND HE WILL BE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MODERATOR WE PLEASE
CONNECT US FIRST WITH LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SUPERVISOR HOLLY
MITCHELL WELCOME BACK SUPERVISE.
CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN. OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH ABOUT
AND SURE I APPRECIATE IT I HAVE
TO TELL YOU I MISS YOU ALL
MEMBERS ON TO PROVIDE THE HOLLY
MITCHELL PROUDLY REPRESENTED L.
A. COUNTY UP. I THINK SECOND
DISTRICT AND I'M HERE BEFORE
YOU SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE WHICH IS-
COSPONSORED BY THE COUNTY
BALLET. I HAVE TO SHARE WITH
YOU ALL IRONICALLY I AM
LITERALLY. VISITING A PROJECT
HOME KEEP SITE IN MY DISTRICT
AS WE SPEAK. I KNOW THE
COMMITTEE IS WELL AWARE THAT WE
HAVE A GROWING HOMELESS CRISIS
AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT WE
ALREADY REACH THE CATASTROPHIC
STATE PEOPLE HERE IN L. A.
COUNTY. AND AS A RESULT OF THAT
BE BELIEVED THAT ONE TIME STATE
HOMELESS FUNDING ALLOCATIONS
WILL NEVER FULLY ADDRESS A
CHRONIC SYSTEMIC PROBLEM YOU IN
THE CRISIS. THAT CREATES A
SITUATION IN WHICH FAMILIES I
TOLD I HAD MET HERE TODAY FIND
THEMSELVES IN. L. A. COUNTY A
FABRIC. OPPORTUNITY TO
ESTABLISH AND STRENGTHEN THAT
COUNTY WIDE ALL THE SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEM LARGELY FUELED
BY LOCALLY GENERATED REVENUE. I
THINK MEASURE H. BACK IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO COUNTY AND OUR
PARTNERS HAVE DOUBLED THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS MOVING
FROM HOMELESSNESS INTO
PERMANENT HOUSING EACH YEAR WE
HAVE DOUBLED IT BASED ON. THE
COMMITMENT VOTERS NAY IN
FUNDING THAT YOU'RE RIGHT. BUT
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE BECOMING
HOMELESS CONTINUES TO OUTPACE
THE NUMBER WE CAN- POWDER BEER
FOR EXAMPLE IN TWENTY NINETEEN
AND ADVOCATE TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY PEOPLE HOW DALY. BUT
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN NEW
PEOPLE FELL INTO HOMELESSNESS
DURING THE SAME PERIOD. DO THE
HOUSING COSTS IT AND OTHER
CRITICAL FACTORS. THEREFORE
DESPITE THE PROGRESS L. A.
COUNTY MAKE THE DATE WITHOUT
THE ON GOING STATE FUNDING
COMMITMENTS PROVIDED IN THIS
BILL AB SEVENTY ONE L. A.
COUNTY IN OTHER COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO TURN THIS IMPORTANT
TIED AND REDBIRDS. YES GROW IN
HOMELESSNESS. NOTE AB SO ONE
WOULD ENABLE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO IMPLEMENT TO BE A RAY OF
EVIDENCE BASED INTERVENTIONS
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS THE VERY
NEED SPACE ALL THE FAMILIES
BIGELOW DAHLE DALY USED IN
THEIR STRUGGLE TO SECURE
HOUSING AND THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF THE CHILD THAT
THE CRITICAL FACTOR. AB SEVENTY
ONE LAYS OUT A LONG TERM
HOLISTIC APPROACH WITH
PROVISIONS THAT HOLD LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS RECEIVING EIGHTY
SEVENTY ONE FUNDED ACCOUNTABLE
TO SHOW MEASURABLE STEADY
PROGRESS. TOWARD ACHIEVING LONG
TERM GOAL. FOR MY FIRST WHAT
CRITICALLY BUT THE IS DAD
DRIVEN APPROACH. WILL LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO CONFRONT SYSTEMIC
RACIAL INEQUITIES THAT
REINFORCED DISPROPORTIONATE
RATES OF HOMELESSNESS AMONG.
PEOPLE OF COLOR LARGELY THAT
NAKED AFTER THE MERICAN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME
TO PRESENT TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. YOUR
EYEBALLS AB SEVENTY ONE. THANK
YOU SUPERVISING GOOD TO HEAR
YOUR VOICE WITH THE MODERATOR
NOW PLEASE CONNECT US WITH.
COUNCILMAN RIDLEY THOMAS PLEASE.
SHE. SHARE WE CAN HEAR YOU. I'M
SURE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
MONITORS FREAK. USE A DANCE
RECORD OF AB SEVENTY ONE AND IS
ON THEY HAVE TO OF THE BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME COALITION. SOME
OF THE WORLD WE CALL THOSE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THE GOVERNOR
NEWSOM APPOINTED ME TO. SERVICE
CO CHAIR. OF HIS NEW COUNCIL OR
REGIONAL HOMELESS ADVISORS AND
I WAS A GROUP WORKING. WELL ON
THIS VERY CRITICAL MATTER
ELECTED OFFICIALS NON PROFIT
LEADERS FROM ACROSS THE STATE
CHARGED WITH MAPPING PROPOSALS
THAT WOULD REDUCE. HOMELESSNESS
I SHOULD SAY THE THEM THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS THE EPICENTER
OF HOMELESSNESS AND THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES AT THE EPICENTER
OF HOMELESSNESS IN. THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES THE EPICENTER OF
HOMELESSNESS IN THE COUNTY OF
LOS SABES. CONCENTRIC CIRCLES
LOW HOMELESSNESS DRIVERS. HELLO
TO THEM BRACE AB SEVENTY ONE
WITH ALL OF OUR MIGHT. WE KNOW
HOW THAT WORKED AT THE- POINTED
COMMITTEE BY THE GOVERNOR DID-
PUT FORTH MULTIPLE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THAT REPORT
WE WERE CLEAR WE NEEDED A STATE
WIDE STRATEGY AND A COMMITMENT
OF ON GOING ANNUAL STATE
FUNDING TO COMBAT THIS CRISIS.
BOB THIS IS SIMPLY. THE PLANE
CRASH NO WAY AROUND IT IF WE
WANT TO DO WELL WE NEED TO LEAN
IN AND AB SEVENTY ONE IS A
DIRECT REFLECTION OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
OBJECTION RENTS IN THE LATE
WITH THE INVESTMENT OF MEASURE
H. TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND
UNDERGO THE SAFETY NET FOR
DECADES HAS SHOWN ITSELF TO BE
A VERY VERY EFFECTIVE- BUT I
MUST HASTEN TO MAKE THE POINT.
THAT MEASURE H. IS SIMPLY
INSUFFICIENT AND WEBER AB
SEVENTY ONE WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A HISTORIC
CHANGE NOT BIND AGAIN
HOMELESSNESS AND MOVE TOWARDS
ESTABLISHING THE RIGHT TO
HOUSING FRAMEWORK AND THAT WILL
REQUIRE THE GOVERNMENT TO
PROVIDE THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE SERVICES RELATED TO
PREVENTION AND FROM HOUSING
PERMANENT HOUSING AND ST
ENGAGEMENT. MANAGER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO WISH
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. THAT YOU
VOTE ONLINE ON A. B. SEVENTY
ONE TODAY AND. MOVE THIS
LEGISLATION FORWARD. IT NOTHING
LESS. THAN APPROACH AND I THANK
YOU. THANK YOU COUNCILMAN THANK
YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON THIS
TOPIC WOOD THE MODERATOR NOW
PLEASE OPEN UP THE MAIN LINE
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
RECORDED OF FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS SHERIN REPORT WITH- ON
BEHALF OF BOTH THE CORPORATION
FOR SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND THE
BRING HOME BRING CALIFORNIA
HOME COALITION JUST MADE UP OF
OVER THREE HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS ENDORSING THE
POLICY OF AB SEVENTY ONE. WERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TWO LINE A SIXTY
SIX YEAR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MECOLE MORTAL MEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP BUT ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AN EXTRA BOTTLE LINE OF EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS ANITA MARKHAM FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I'M A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS. I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANEXO HOTEL LINE OF EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON NICCOLO
DELUCA BEHALF OF THE OAKLAND
MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF IN THE OPEN
CITY COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S LEADERSHIP ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXAVAR LINE OF FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AT THE END OF THE DAY
AND YOU'RE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS PROBABLY CHAPTER
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THE BIG THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
TO BOTTOM LINE OF SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MARC STIVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND NEXT
SO GO TO LINE OF NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY SHAW ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AN EXTROVERT A
LINE OF NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS JULIE
SNYDER REPRESENTING THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE WE ARE A
PROUD CO SPONSOR THIS MEASURE
AND REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON WITH MONICA
LEWIS FROM TOPIC THE LOS
ANGELES I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE STEERING COMMITTEE OF BRING
CALIFORNIA HONG KONG THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND ACCESSIBLE
TO LINE OF NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
PHILADELPHIA CRANK CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY AT
HOME IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANEXO GO TO LINE OF
ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS FROM A DOCTOR AND I
LIVE IN THE CITY OF SAN JOSE I
AM IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE AND I AM JUST
PLEADING WITH THIS GROUP AND
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. TO
REPLACE REDEVELOPMENT 20%
PANTERAS DE LAMB ALL YOU WANT
NORTH OF MANBIJ. WE NEED YOU TO
SPEAK. ON AB SEVENTY ONE YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
SUPPORT. OUR OPPOSITION WELL MY
DOCTOR. ROBERT JOHNSON AB
SEVENTY ONE SUPPORT NO
AFFILIATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MA'AM. THANK YOU ANEXO PHOTO
LINE OF ONE OH SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. JACK BUILDING GALLERY
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND ACCESSIBLE TO
LINE OF SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AFTERNOON CHAIRED
MEMBERS SUBMITTING A DEJA
QUARREL WITH THE FACT MENTAL
HEALTH ALLIANCE AND I AM A
MEMBER OF THE- PROJECT NEVER
CALLING IS TRUMP RECORDED
EIGHTY SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT LINE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU
HAVE BEEN INJURED MEMBERS AND
BACK FROM THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO SO LINE OF
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ANNA JOHNSON FROM
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN
MEXICO TO LINE UP EIGHTY. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MAJOR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ANDREW M. TUY
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO GO TO
LINE OF EIGHTY TWO WE ARE LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JOYCE
PROBABLY FROM SAN DIEGO I'M A
MEMBER OF THE MESONET UNITED
NETWORK AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
TOOK A LINE OF THIRTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ACREE
WARM ON BEHALF OF THE DOWNTOWN
WOMEN'S CENTER OF LOS ANGELES
CRABB ALSO PROUD MEMBER OF THE
BRING CALIFORNIA HOME COALITION
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AN EXTRA BOTTLE OUT OF
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH CRUISE
AND KAT I'M A FORMER FOSTER
CALLING FROM THE TRACK
CALIFORNIA. TO SUPPORT. SUPPORT
FOR AB SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON- THIS IS JORDAN
JOHNSON CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION
CALLING A STRONG SUPPORT FOR
YOU'D BE SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU
ANEXO GO TO LINE OF THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARLIN
DEREK PRIOR ON A MEMBER F THE
BRING CALIFORNIA HOME COALITION
I AM STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
YOU AN EXTRA COAT SO LINE OF
ABOUT NINETY SIX FEEL AND IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ALLISON RADIUM I LIVE IN SANTA
MONICA CALIFORNIA I MEMBER OF
SURROUNDING RESIDENTS UNITED
NETWORK AND I MEAN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO A LINE OF THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ALAN KNIGHT I AM A
FORMERLY HOMELESS CONSTITUENTS.
IN SUN VALLEY I AM ALSO A
MEMBER OF RESIDENT UNITED
NETWORK CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE SAVE MY LIVES AND THE
LIVES OF OTHERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NXR GO TO LINE OF
LINE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL MAY
BE THEY'LL I'M CALLING FROM THE
ENTRY OPPORTUNITY CAMPAIGN TO
END POVERTY IN CONTRA COSTA AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
DAMIEN SCOTT WITH THE EAST BAY
HOUSING ORGANISATIONS IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SIX GOOD
AFTERNOON GENERAL KNOWLEDGE
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON ONE
PROPERTY AND CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT AB SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO OF FIFTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TO
ENSURE NUMBERS MY NAME IS ROSE
JONATHAN FROM HUMBOLDT COUNTY
AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND
THEY CURRENTLY HAVE A TICKET
CALLING SHARM SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND ACCESSIBLE
TO LINE OF SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MEXICO
CAROLINA OF WHAT ONE OH NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MICHAEL RAT
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANEXO GO TO LINE UP
AT THIRTY FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
ACTUALLY- CALLING ON BEHALF OF
PATH PEOPLE ASSISTING THE
HOMELESS CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB SEVENTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MEXICO
TIMELINE OF SEVENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOONMY NAME
IS MARIE VERNON I'M FOUNDER OF
THE CALIFORNIA WOMAN BOARD
COALITION I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE RESIDENTS UNITED NETWORK
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU. MEXICO
CAROLINA OF FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DAN BRADLEY I'M FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I'M A
MEMBER OF THE RESIDENTS UNITED
WITH NETWORK COLLEEN IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO OF
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS CODY VAN
HELDEN IM FROM SACRAMENTO I AM
A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND ACCESSIBLE TO A LINE OF
FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TWENTY TWO S<c.cyan> CALLING FROM</c>
SACRAMENTO AND THE RESIDENTS
UNITED NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY ONE.
THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE OF
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS FRANCISCO GARCIA I'M
CALLING FROM SACRAMENTO ALL
WITH MUTUAL HOUSING CALIFORNIA
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF RESIDENT
UNITED NETWORK IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU MEXICO
TO LINE UP AT FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS A VERY I'M A FOSTER
YOUTH AND YOUTH ADVOCATE HERE
IN FULL SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN
I THINK YEAH. THANK YOU. MEXICO
SO LINE OF A SIXTY THREE YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
THERESA WINKLER I'M A IN THE
LAST CENTURY. YEAH DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES- OF THAT SITTING UNITED
NETWORK AND I AM STRONG SUPPORT
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. XO BOTTLE LINE OF EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS IS ALEX THE SHOPKEEPER IN
THE LOS ANGELES HOMELESS
SERVICES AUTHORITY AND WERE A
PROUD SUPPORTER OF AB SEVENTY
ONE. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF
ONE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ALICE DALY
CAMPUS- THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WILL HOUSING AND
RESIDENCE UNITED NETWORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE- WE WORK
ON THIS. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE OF FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE FOUR EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU HAVE A
W. HELLO GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MANORCARE MY NAME IS
SYLVIA- CUNNINGHAM. FROM
OAKLAND ALL THEY HAVE TO
RESIDENTS THE UNITED NETWORK
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY ONE.
THANK YOU. MEXICO TIMELINE OF
ONE OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS LAUREN I'M AT THE
RIGHT IN ORDER TO WORK AND I'M
CALLING BECAUSE I AM A BIG FAN
ANYONE. THANK YOU MEXICO
CAROLINA THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK THIS AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
WILLIAM GOOD ONE I AM CALLING
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FOURTEEN
PITTSBURG CALIFORNIA I'M A
MEMBER OF THE REGIME ONE
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY ONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT
SOKOTO LINED A ONE OUT TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI YES THIS IS-
QUICKER TO KILL BALLING CALLING
FROM WEST HOLLYWOOD ON BEHALF
OF THE RESIDENTS UNITED NETWORK
IN THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
LOCATION OF NONPROFIT HOUSING
BOTH ORGANIZATIONS AREN'T
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
ONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU BY
NEXT TO BOTTOM LINE OF ONE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS REGINA SHIPMENT I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROVIDER HOPES SOLUTION
POORLY CONTRA COSTA INTERFAITH
HOUSING IN STRONG SUPPORT
CONTINUES SOURCE OF FUNDING AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU MEXICO CAROLINA
ONE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS TERRENCE THOMPSON
FROM OUR HOME- I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT- AB. SEVENTY ONE. THANK
YOU ANEXO GO TO LINE OF. TWENTY
NINE. I'M SORRY TWENTY NINE IS
NO LONGER THERE WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF ONE NINETEEN. WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF US SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M YES MY MAYOR
FRANCINE ANDRADE I AM PUNCTUAL
ST JOSEPH'S CALIFORNIA. AREN'T
YOU NOT MEMBER OF THE RESIDENT
UNITED NETWORK CALLING TO
SUPPORT. BIG TIME AB SEVENTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AN
EXTRA COAT SO LINE OF ONE NOT
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CALLED HOLY
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF WEST SACRAMENTO A MEMBER OF
THE BRING CALIFORNIA HOME
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT. OF
AB SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU.
MEXICO. TO I'M SORRY WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF US SEVENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
BILLION NINETY I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND NEXT TO BOTTOM LINE OF
ONE AT TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
pCHAIR MEMBERS WITHIN A CAR ONTO
ELLIOT CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF ALAMEDA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
NEXT TOTAL LINE OF- ONE OF
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS
THIS IS ON THAT'S WRONG MOST ON
BEHALF OF PUBLIC ADVOCATES WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
WHAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE UP ONE OF
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND MEXICO TO A LINE OF-
ONE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
BURKE MADAM BY STREAMLINING
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ONCE A
LAURIE ON THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY YOUNG DEMOCRATS AND ON
BEHALF OF THE YOUNG DEMOCRATS I
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE ENCOURAGE OUR
MEMBERS DOUBLE I ON THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PHOTO
LINE- ONE MOMENT. ONE TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS THE IBM MADISON WITH
EMPOWERMENT CONGRESS WHACKING
SOUTH BOSTON'S LIFT AND SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ADMIRERS ON
BEHALF OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN
EXCEL GO TO LINE OF ONE FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THE
DIFFERENT PEOPLE THAT THE
RESIDENTS SACRAMENTO AND A
MEMBER OF PRESIDENT UNITED
NETWORK AND ALSO REPRESENTING
HOUSING CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY ONE.
THANK YOU AND ACCESSIBLE TO
LINE OF ONE FORTY ONE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ROBERT YOU
GOVERNMENT I WORK WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIAN RESIDENTS UNITED
NETWORK AND I WAS FORMALLY CASE
WORKER IN THE RECOVERY WE
HOUSING PROGRAMS AND ECHO PARK
LOS ANGELES. IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANEXO BOTTOM LINE A
ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MY NAME IS THAT THE LAMP
FOR LEN AND I AM AFFILIATED
WITH. NINE YEAR AND I'M IN. THE
QUARTER AB SEVENTY ONE. THANK
YOU MEXICO CAROLINA ONE OF
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS MOLLY DUFFY AND I'M
CALLING FROM RALLY
COMMUNICATION CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MEXICO TIMELINE
OF ONE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN- HELLO MY NAME IS PATRICK
AT IT I AM FROM METER AND I AM
A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS AND IS
CURRENTLY RECEIVING SERVICES.
FROM AT THE FACILITY WHICH
WOULD GET BE HOUNDED BY THE
PROPOSAL AND I AM CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
ONE IMPLORING. VOTED BY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO A
LINE OF ONE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME'S NICOLE
THERE SEEM CALLING FROM
LAFAYETTE CALIFORNIA- JUST
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A
SEVENTY ONE WITH BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME REPRESENTING
OVER THREE HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN
EXTRA COAT SO LINE OF FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE FIFTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DO YOU
HAVE A SIGNED ME OUT. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW.
OKAY SORRY MY NAME IS RICHARD
GALLO I'M FROM SANTA CRUZ
CALIFORNIA I AM A VOLUNTEER
MEMBER OF PRESIDENT UNITED
NETWORK CALL IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANEXO GO TO LINE OF
ONE OF FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ERICA BONTA CALLING ON BEHALF
OF CORPORATIONS FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MEXICO TO LINE UP OUR ONE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE FORTY. GO AHEAD. THE VALUE
OF GOMEZ AND I'M CALLING FROM
COACHELLA CALIFORNIA I AM A
MEMBER OF THE RESIDENT UNITED
NETWORK- AND OUT TO WORK BETTER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF NONPROFIT HOUSING AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANNEX WE GO TO LINE OF ONE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS WILLIE STEVENSON-
WITH- RESIDENTS UNITED NETWORK
AND I'M IN. SUPPORT OF A BIT A.
B. BOB SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANEXO GO TO ALIGN ONE
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME'S CORNING HONESTLY I'M
CALLING FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO
RESIDENT AND I AM JUST CALLING
TO SAM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND I'M SURE WE HAVE NO
FURTHER- SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. I THINK YOU DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES AND THE WITNESSES
CONFERENCING CENTER. NO SEEING
NINE ANY IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SEEING NONE MODERATOR WHICH YOU
OPENED BE ONLINE FOR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. I BELIEVE THERE
ARE TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THE FIRST IS CLIENTS ALL OVER
FROM HIS BED CENTRAL VALLEY.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CLINT OLIVIER AND I'M THE CEO
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY BUSINESS
FEDERATION OR BITS THAT FOR
SHORT. BILLS THAT IS SUPPOSED
TO AB SEVENTY ONE FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS WELL THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS IS A SERIOUS AND
CHRONIC PROBLEM CONFRONTING
CALIFORNIA THE LEGISLATION IS
NOT THE PROPER VEHICLE TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. ACCORDING
TO A STATE AUDIT REPORT ISSUED
IN FEBRUARY CALIFORNIA STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO SPEND
HEAVILY TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
BUT HAVE NOT FOLLOWED A
COORDINATED PLAN AND DON'T
BATES SPENDING ON
EFFECTIVENESS. THE STATE
AUDITOR CONCLUDED THAT
CALIFORNIA'S QUOTE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS IS
DISJOINTED AND QUOTE AND THAT
THE STATE QUOTE CONTINUES TO
LACK A COMPREHENSIVE
UNDERSTANDING OF IT SPENDING TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS THE
SPECIFIC SERVICES BUT PROGRAMS
PROVIDE OR THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
RECEIVE THOSE SERVICES AND
QUOTE. GOVERNOR NEW SINCE
JANUARY BUDGET HAS A RECORD
RESERVE A TWENTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS AND CALIFORNIA'S
ESTIMATED TO HAVE A FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLAR REVENUE WINDFALL
FROM HIGHER THAN ANTICIPATED
TAX REVENUE. ADDITIONALLY
CALIFORNIA WILL RECEIVE FUNDS
FROM THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
ACT WHICH INCLUDES FUNDS
EARMARKED FOR HOMELESSNESS IN
SHORT TAX INCREASES ARE NOT
NECESSARY ESPECIALLY IF
CALIFORNIA. BEGINS ITS ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. THE STATE HELLO
GOVERNMENT SHOULD REFINE THEIR
APPROACH TO IDENTIFY ROGRAMS
THAT WORK TO FIGHT AGAINST THIS
CHRONIC ISSUE INCREASING TAXES
IS NOT THE SOLUTION. PRIOR TO
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC MANY
BUSINESSES RELOCATED FROM
CALIFORNIA TO OTHER LOW COST
LOWER TAX STATES. ADDING MORE
TAXES DURING THIS PERIOD IS NOT
HELPFUL TO CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES IT WILL HINDER THE
STATE ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
AFFECT STATE AND IMPORTANTLY
LOCAL TAX REVENUE AS WELL. AS
FOR THE WATER'S EDGE ISSUE IT'S
NOT A LOOPHOLE AS SOME WOULD
ARGUE WHEN IN REALITY IT'S A
FUNDAMENTAL PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S TAX STRUCTURE. IT
IS A NECESSITY THAT IN LARGE
PART CAME ABOUT BECAUSE OF
DIRECTION FROM THE UNITED
STATES GOVERNMENT D. EASE
RISING TENSIONS WITH OUR
INTERNATIONAL TRADING PARTNERS
WHO OBJECTED TO CALIFORNIA
INFRINGING ON THEIR TRADE
AGREEMENTS WITH THE UNITED
STATES. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NOTEBOOK
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE ONE
OTHER. THAT'S THE TWO MINUTE
TIMER AND I WANT OTHER
OPPOSITION LONG. SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY MANUFACTURING
ASSOCIATION. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN- I REPRESENT- THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY MANUFACTURING
ALLIANCE WHICH- HAS THIRTEEN
HUNDRED MEMBERS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY LOCATED IN FRESNO- WE
ARE IN OPPOSE ANY OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL. FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS- WHAT I AM ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF FRESNO
RESCUE MISSION WHICH- IS DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO PROVIDE
FOR THE HOMELESS- IN THE FRESNO
AREA. AND THIS BILL DOES NOT
BEGIN TO ADDRESS THE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND ADDICTION
ISSUES THAT ARE REALLY THE
CENTER OF HOMELESSNESS- IT'S
CERTAINLY IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL HAS THE SUPPORT OF
THE LOCAL NONPROFITS THE FAITH
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
DOING ALL THE WORK ON THE
GROUND RIGHT NOW FOR MOST OF IT
HERE IN THE FRESNO AREA. AND
THAT THIS BILL. DOESN'T SEEM TO
SUPPORT THEM IN ANY WAY IN FACT
IT PROBABLY REAP PLACES SOME OF
THE FUNDING OTHER THING MAY BE
CURRENTLY GETTING. WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A
MASSIVE BUREAUCRACY THAT IS
JUST GOING TO EAT UP MORE AND
MORE OF THE MONEY- THAT IS
ALLOCATED TO IT ONLY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CREATING. AND ADDING
OR CREATING DATA COLLECTION-
WHICH IS GOING TO BE EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE. WHERE IN OPPOSITION-
FOR THE BILL- THE- TAXATION
PORTIONS OF IT HAVE BEEN
REMOVED BUT THERE ARE STILL A
NUMBER OF OTHER PORTIONS OF THE
TAXATION AS I READ IT- IS STILL
IN PLACE AND WE WOULD BE
IMPOSED TO THAT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I WITH
MARI PLEASE OPEN THE MAIN LINE
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU IN
OPPOSITION. FOR TODAY AT AB
SEVENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
THEY'RE OFF THEIR OPPOSITION.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF SIXTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS MATT REGAN CALLING ABOUT THE
BAY AREA COUNSELOR THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EMPLOYER
MEMBERS AND STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JUSTIN HIGHER
FROM THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE MUST
ALSO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
BILL THE TIME THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO WHAT THE LINE OF
ONE OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JOHN LINGER ON BEHALF OF THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ADVAMED ALSO AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE LEVIN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS IS CHRIS WYSOCKI WITH
WESTERN MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES AT THE STATION AND
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE- THIS
MEASURE- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. NXR GO TO LINE OF
THE EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON PRESTIN
YOUNG FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HERE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE OF ONE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
MORE TO GAIN ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION OF
RESPECTIVE POST. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE A ONE OH FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PETER WALKER
OF THE CALGARY TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION SAYS. THANK YOU
MEXICO CAROLINA FORTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THE ANY PACKET ON BEHALF OF
TECHNET AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO CAROLINA OF EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AN EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. K. NEXT
TO GO TO LINE UP ONE SIXTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
KRISTIN CONNELLY ON BEHALF OF
THE EAST BAY LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
REPRESENTING HUNDREDS OF THE
SAME PLAYERS WITH- AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE STYLE.
THANK YOU AND MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION LEFT IN Q.
GREAT THANK YOU WITH A IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING CENTER. NO I
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NINE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY WE'VE GOT A LOT
OF WELL I'LL START THE SAME
DOCTOR BURKE AND WILLS FOR
FRIEND- WELL I'M ALWAYS IN
FAVOR OF CONFORMITY- SO FIRST-
BUT I'M- MAKE A MOTION FOR THE
BELL SECOND. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO OF ALL OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS GOT A HUGE TAX
BREAK WHICH DID NOTHING TO HELP
THE ECONOMY. DID NOTHING EXCEPT
FEDERAL MAKE FEDERAL DEBTS
LARGER IT'S TIME THAT THEY HELP
PAY FOR THE PROBLEMS THE STATE
HAS THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS PROPOSAL FORWARD
I DO APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR FOCUS
AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESSING WHAT IS ONE OF- THE
CRISES FACING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- COUPLE OF. AREAS
THAT I WANTED TO GET INTO A
LITTLE BIT SO FIRST CAN YOU
JUST SPEAK TO THE OPPOSITION'S
POINT THAT THIS EFFECTIVELY
UNDERMINES THE WATER'S EDGE
ELECTION. BECAUSE I'M HAVING A
HARD TIME CAN WRAP MY HEAD
AROUND THAT SURE I'M GOING TO
ASK- I HAVE A- THE WITNESS.
PROFESSOR SHEN SKI- THAT COULD
SPEAK TO THE TECHNICAL
PROVISIONS JANSKY ON THE
ASSEMBLY. A LOT OF THE LINE CAN
YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU
WELCOME THAT DID YOU HEAR THE
QUESTION. IT WAS ABOUT THE
WATER THAT ELECTION YES YES THE
OPPOSITION HAS MADE A POINT
THAT THIS EFFECTIVELY
UNDERMINES THE WATER'S EDGE
ELECTION AND- WOULD BRING US
INTO A INTERNATIONAL TRADE WORK
IF YOU COULD JUST SPEAK TO.
THAT POINT. YES I WOULD.
RESPECTFULLY ON DISK DISAGREE
WITH THAT- THE WATER THAT
ELECTION- DID COME ABOUT- IN
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES BECAUSE
THE PRESSURE ON FROM OUR
SCREENING PARTNERS AND SO THAT
PART. IS TRUE BUT WHAT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND OR BOOK
A LOT OF THINGS AND APART
UNDERSTAND EVERYTHING FIRST OF
ALL. EVEN AT THE TIME OF THE
WATERCRESS ELECTIONS WHICH
BASICALLY MEANS THAT.
CALIFORNIA I'M CORPORATION TAP
THE OPTION TO JUST REPORT ON
THERE TO- TO MASTER KERNING
SEPARATE FROM THEIR FARM
EARNINGS EVEN THAT IS PART OF
THE ORIGINAL WATERS AT
SELECTION. CALIFORNIA CONFORMS
TO FEDERAL CORPORATE TAX LAW
AND BROUGHT IN A SLICE OF
SUSPICIOUS FOREIGN EARNINGS
KNOWN AS SUBPART AT. THOSE
ALWAYS THE CASE. THAT
CALIFORNIA'S WATER. GRADUAL
ACTION INCLUDED. ALEXION ARE
INCLUDED INCOME NOMINALLY
EARNED ABROAD IN THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS. SO ALL THIS BILL
DOES IS SAY THAT THE TAX CUTS
AND JOBS ACT RECOGNIZED THAT
THE OLD REGIME INCLUDING SUB
PAR THAT WAS NOT WORKING VERY
WELL IN TERMS OF COMBATING
INCOME STRIP BEING. CREATED A
NEW CATEGORY OF INCOME DEEMED
SUSPICIOUS AND LIKELY SHIFTED
OUT OF THE DOMESTIC TAX BASE
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
BRINGS THAT. INCOME BACK INTO
THE DOMESTIC TAX BASE I THOUGHT
ALL CALIFORNIA WOULD DO WOULD
BE CONFORMED AND TO DO THE VERY
SAME THING. BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
WOULD BE CONFORMING TO WHAT THE
FEDS ALREADY KILLING THE NOTION
OF THIS IS GONNA SIMPLE OIL
CALIFORNIA- IN SOME WAY WITH
OUR TRADE PARTNERS IN SOME
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT DOING WHAT
THE FEDS ARE DOING. IS NOT
ACCURATE. FURTHERMORE THE IS
CHANGE. ALL WITH INCOMES
STRIPPING IS NOW PERCEIVED AS A
MAJOR PROBLEM THAT THE OECD
COUNTRIES INCLUDING THE UNITED
STATES INCLUDING- RIGHT NOW
SECRETARY ALLEN VERY IS VERY
ACTIVELY ENGAGING WITH- DEALING
WITH- THE PROBLEM OF INCOME
SHIFTING INTERNATIONALLY
INCLUDING- HAVING INTERNATIONAL
TYPE GUILTY REGIMES AND SO THE
NOTION THAT OUR TRADING
PARTNERS WHAT A JACK IN THE WAY
THEY DID IN THE EIGHTIES ITSELF
HIGHLY IMPROBABLE. THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR THAT PROFESSOR CAN
CAN OPPOSITION REPLY TO THAT
AND TO THE OPPOSITION HERE THAT.
DR SHAMS- PROFESSORSHIP SKIS
ANALYSIS. WOULD ANYONE OF THE
OPPOSITION LIKE TO RESPOND TO
DOT- PROFESSOR SJAM SKIS-
ANALYSIS ON THE WATER'S EDGE.
EXACTLY ONLY BE A FROM HIS BED
THANK YOU. GO AHEAD- YOU YOU WE
ARE WE TAKE THE POSITION THAT
THE AS I STATED THAT IT IS NOT
A LOOPHOLE- AND THAT AS THE IS
BEING ARGUED BUT WE THINK IT'S
A FUNDAMENTAL PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S TAX STRUCTURE- AND
POP OBVIOUSLY WHERE WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO EIGHTY SEVENTY ONE
BUT LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING HOW
THE ISSUE WORKS OUT IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I DO HAVE I DO
HAVE ONE OTHER QUESTION WHICH
ACTUALLY I THINK. IT HAS MORE
TO DO WITH BECAUSE- CERTAINLY
WE HAVE WHICH IS SEEMINGLY
INTRACTABLE AND CATASTROPHIC
CHALLENGE ON OUR HANDS WE LOOK
AT OUR OUR HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
AND IF WE LOOK AT THE LACK OF
PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE AS A
STATE MIKE MY QUESTION REALLY
IS HOW MUCH OF THAT IS. A
REVENUE PROBLEM VERSUS HOW MUCH
OF THAT IS PERFORMANCE PROBLEM
AN EIGHT YEAR I THINK MONDAY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES POINTED
TO. THE AUDITORS FAIRLY
SCATHING AUDIT THAT. A BIG PART
OF THE ISSUE IS THAT WE JUST
HAVE A TOTAL LACK OF
COORDINATION AMONGST OUR
AGENCIES WE HAVE A LACK IN A
NOTE TELLING YOU POINTED OUT.
OF DATA DRIVEN ASSESSMENT ABOUT
WHAT'S WORKING AND WHAT'S NOT
AND- I PRETTY WORRIED THAT IN
THE ABSENCE OF FIXING SOME OF
THE STRUCTURAL ISSUES FIRST.
KIND OF POURING GOOD MONEY
AFTER BAD SO. AND CAN USE I
GUESS CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT
AND- SURE I'D BE HAPPY TO AND
I'M GLAD THAT. WE BROUGHT UP
THE STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT IN
THIS HEARING. BECAUSE IN
ADDITION TO- CALLING FOR MORE
COORDINATION LIKE YOU
MENTIONED- IT ALSO CALLS ON
ADDITIONAL AND DEDICATED
FUNDING. TOWARDS HOMELESSNESS
THAT SAME REPORT- THAT WAS
MENTIONED ALSO CALLS FOR THIS
RATE AND- YOU KNOW I HAD A BILL
LAST YEAR- I KNOW THAT- YOU'RE
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH IT- THAT
WOULD HAVE. BROUGHT ALL OUR
PROGRAMS WITHIN THE STATE UNDER
ONE OFFICE- AND I'VE BEEN. I'VE
CONTINUED WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE
GOVERNANCE PIECE THAT IS
SOMETHING I'M VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK- AND WE HAVE COME UP WITH
A BILL. OF AB TWELVE TWENTY
THAT. WORKS ON THE REFORM OF
THE HOMELESSNESS GOVERNANCE
FROM THE STATE'S PERSPECTIVE.
BUT IN ADDITION THIS BILL DOES
HAVE SOME ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES. RECAP INCLUDED IN IT-
YOU KNOW WE WILL BE COLLECTING
DATA. OF THAT THROUGH THERE'S A
REQUIREMENT FOR THIS PROGRAM TO
BE AUDITED BY AN INDEPENDENT
AUDITOR EVERY FOUR YEARS. SO WE
WILL BE YOU KNOW THE
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT I KNOW A
LOT OF MEMBERS ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT I AM TOO- IS. IS PART OF
THIS PROGRAM. WHAT THINK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT I'M LIKE
BECAUSE I'M SURE HE'LL BUT I
WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY I. REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU
WERE DOING I HAVE TO IMPROVE
ACCOUNTABILITY TO IMPROVE
OVERSIGHT TO IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY SO. I DO LOOK FOR
TO PARTNERING WITH YOU ON THAT
MAP ON THAT ASPECT OF THIS THIS
IMPORTANT AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTIONS THANKS- AND JUST
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND WE HAVE
WORKED AND HAVE LONG
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SPONSORS
OF THE BILL I'M TAP THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS MOVING FORWARD
AS A GOING TO HOUSING. OTHER
THOSE ISSUES BE THOROUGHLY
ADDRESS THEY WERE DRESSED A
LITTLE BIT BUT FRONT THOROUGHLY
ADDRESSED MOVING FORWARD.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND TO STATE-
WELL THANK YOU ALSO TO THE
AUTHOR FOR YOUR PASSION- FOR
THIS- ISSUE TO STATE THAT-
CALIFORNIA HAS A HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS IS. A HUGE
UNDERSTATEMENT. AND SO I GET
THAT- I THINK SEEING AGAIN
MAKING REFERENCE TO THE STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT. SEEING THE
THRTEEN BILLION. HAS BEEN
SPENT ON HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. SPEAKS VOLUMES TO THE
FACT THAT YOU HAVE TO ASK
YOURSELF THE QUESTION. IS
POURING MORE MONEY INTO THIS
THE ANSWER OR IS THERE A BIGGER
ISSUE- THAT WE HAVE. AT HAND I
THINK THE- THE GREATEST
ACCOMPLISHMENT THAT THIS BILL
DOES AND IS WORTHY OF SUPPORT
IS THE FACT THAT. YOU'RE
LOOKING LONG TERM THIS IS YOUR
LOOKING FOR A SUSTAINABLE
SOURCE OF REVENUE THAT IS GOING
TO ADDRESS A CRISIS. IN THE
LONG TERM RATHER THAN HAVING
DEPEND ON COMING WITH YOUR HAND
OUT EVERY SINGLE YEAR LOOKING
FOR A ONE TIME ALLOCATION
HOWEVER HAVING ALLOCATED
THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS IN A
THREE YEAR PERIOD. AND TO STILL
SEE THE KIND OF CRISIS THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT I HEARD THE URGENCY
THAT CAME FROM WITNESSES
TESTIMONY THAT WE HAVE MORE
PEOPLE ENTERING INTO
HOMELESSNESS. ALL RIGHT NOW
THEN WE THEN WE ARE TAKING OFF
THE STREETS. AND THE AND SO I
SEE THAT BUT I ALSO SEE WHERE
THERE'S AN OPEN DOOR TO ADDRESS
A CHALLENGE OR PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE IN THE STATE. THAT IS A
REVENUE ORIENTED BUT THAT IS
SERVICE ORIENTED AND SO WHEN WE
START LOOKING AT THAT WE'VE GOT
TO FIND OUT WHAT SERVICES ARE
WORKING AND WHAT SERVICES
AREN'T. SO WITH THAT I MEAN THE
AUDITOR HAD POINTED OUT THAT WE
HAVE FORTY HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS WITH LITTLE
COORDINATION BETWEEN NINE STATE
AGENCIES. AND WITH BILLIONS
THAT ARE BEING SPENT. WE HAVE
THE ISSUE OF REALLY A SYSTEM
THAT HAS BEEN SET UP TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. AND IS FAILING
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE MOST IN
NEED I HEARD THE OTHER SIDE THE
OPPOSITION AND THEIR TESTIMONY
AND I CAN UNDERSTAND THE
FRUSTRATION OF WHY THEY FEEL
WHY DO WE NEED MORE MONEY WE'RE
NOT EVEN. BENEFITING FROM WHAT
WE HAVE AND IT'S BECAUSE THE
SYSTEM REALLY ISN'T GETTING THE
ANSWER INTO THE HANDS OF THOSE
THAT CAN MEET THE NEED. AND SO
WITH THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY BUT- WILL. ONLY
MAKE THE WORD BUT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
HOWEVER. ALONG WITH BEING ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THERE HAS TO BE SOME
EVIDENCE. OF MEANINGFUL REFORM.
OF AND I APPRECIATE THE BILL
THAT YOU PROPOSED LAST YEAR AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
ADDITIONAL BILL THAT YOU HAVE
THIS YEAR. I'M NOT SEEING THE
STRONG REFORM THAT IS NEEDED IN
THIS BILL. BUT A TIED I KNOW
YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL AND IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL MOVING FORWARD FROM
THIS COMMITTEE- IF THERE HAS TO
BE SOME EVIDENCE FROM
ADMINISTRATION- TO SUPPORT
MEANINGFUL REFORM. SO THAT WE
DON'T CONTINUE WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING FOR THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS. OF THROWING- MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF RIGHT- OF MANY TAX
DOLLARS- INTO A SPACE THAT WE
CAN ACCOUNT FOR AND IT'S
OBVIOUSLY NOT MEETING THE NEED.
SO WITH THAT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY BUT
ALSO LOOKING FOR EVIDENCE OF
REFORM. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- MEMBERS. HOMELESSNESS IS
AN AREA I'VE HAD SOME
EXPERIENCE WITH. MY ENTIRE LIFE
I WAS RAISED IN A CHURCH THAT
CHOSE TO TAKE ON THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS AS THEIR MAIN
MISSION- WE ACTUALLY WENT SO
FAR AS TO HOUSING PEOPLE IN THE
CHURCH AT ONE POINT WHEN THE
CITY REFUSED. TO MAKE PROPER
ACCOMMODATIONS. AND I'VE SPENT
A GOOD BOOK OF THE TEN YEARS
I'VE BEEN HERE IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE WORKING ON ALMOST
THIS IN MY AREA WHICH WHICH IS
GRANTED A RURAL COMMUNITY VERY
UNLIKE. YOUR WHOLE. AND THE
MORE I DIG IN THE MORE I'VE
LEARNED. OVER THE YEARS HE IS
JUST SO BONTA CLEAR THAT. THE
ISSUES RAISED FROM MY
COLLEAGUES HERE. ON ON PROCESS
AND BUREAUCRACY AND
COLLABORATION- ARE SO VERY TRUE
AND FROM. THIS RURAL
LEGISLATORS POINT OF VIEW WHAT
I SEE AGAIN AND AGAIN IS
LEGISLATORS FROM LA. WHO WOULD
JUST AS SOON. SPEND AS MUCH
MONEY AS THEY CAN AND THERE'S
NEVER ENOUGH AND WE ALWAYS NEED
TO RAISE MORE AND THERE'S
ALWAYS SOMEONE ELSE WE NEED TO
TAX AND YET I GOT UNDERWAY IN
SKID ROW JUST GOES ON AS FAR AS
THE EYE CAN SEE. THANK MORE
MONEY WE SPEND THE LONGER THE
BLOCKS GET. AND IT SEEMS TO BE
FROM AN OUTSIDER'S PERSPECTIVE
A REFLECTION OF THE FACT THAT
URBAN LEGISLATORS ARE SO OFTEN
SO DEEPLY INVESTED IN THE
SPECIAL INTERESTS WHETHER IT BE
THE UNIONS OR THE- NRDC OR THAT
WHAT WHATEVER CONSTITUENCY
PROGRESSIVE AWAY LEGISLATORS
FEEL LIKE THEY CAN'T TAKE ON.
THEY CAN'T MAKE ANY PROGRESS
AGAINST THE NAME DAYS THEY
CAN'T BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR LESS THAN WHAT IT COST TO
BUILD A MANSION WHERE I LIVE-
ANY GETS PULLED AND I GUESS
WHAT I SEE HERE IN THE MIDST
OF. ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY IN THE
COVERT CRISIS AND SO MANY
CHALLENGING ISSUES BUT I KNOW
WE'RE ALL FACING AND OR OR
COMMUTER FACING. I THINK WHO IN
THEIR RIGHT MIND. WOULD SAY NOW
IS THE TIME FOR ANY KIND OF TAX
INCREASE ON ANYBODY. RIGHT IT
AND WE'RE SPENT THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS I THINK I
HEARD. FROM MY COLLEAGUE- AND
SO IT'S I GUESS IT'S JUST KIND
OF A HEAD SCRATCHING MOMENT FOR
ME. I APPLAUD YOU FOR TAKE ON
ISSUES I THINK WE ALL RECOGNIZE
IS IMPORTANT. I THINK I
VEHEMENTLY DISAGREE WITH YOU ON
PERHAPS THE APPROACH AND I
THINK WE NEED TO REALLY DOUBLE
OUR EFFORTS IN. CREATE YOU KNOW
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS WHERE
REVENUE GOES TO IT GOES TO AND
HOW THEY WORK TOGETHER BETWEEN
THE COUNTIES THE COCS- THESE
THESE ORGANIZATIONS DON'T WORK
TOGETHER WE SPENT QUITE A BIT
OF MONEY ON HOMELESSNESS AND
WHAT I'VE DONE IN MY HOME TOWN.
IS ACTUALLY PULLED EVERY CITY
AND THE COUNTY. COLLABORATIVELY
POTENTIALLY MAKING THAT MONEY
GO AND STRETCH A LOT FURTHER
AND SO I DON'T THINK I'M GONNA
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE DAY THIS
BILL TODAY UNLESS IN YOUR
RESPONSE TO MY QUESTION HERE
YOU DO WONDERS AND CONVINCE ME
THAT. MY PERSPECTIVE IS SO.
INACCURATE- BUT I WOULD HOPE.
THAT IF THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD- IF YOU COULD DO
SOMETHING TO ADDRESS THE OTHER
ISSUES THE NIMBYISM. YOU KNOW
THE- THE NO GROSS-
ENVIRONMENTAL EXTREMISM SOME
THESE ISSUES THAT EXIST IN THE
URBAN AREAS BECAUSE WHAT IT'S
DOING IS YOU GUYS AE PUSHING
YOUR POPULATIONS OUT AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES DRIVING UP THE COST
OF HOUSING. YOU DON'T BUILD
ROADS YOU FORCE PEOPLE ON THE
ROADS LONG COMMUTES WE CAN'T
BUILD ROADS BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
DO CLIMATE CHANGE. POLICIES WE
CAN'T SOLVE PROBLEMS- AND THEY
JUST GET WORSE AND WORSE AND
WORSE SO IF YOU CAN STICK SOME.
LANGUAGE IN HERE IN THE NEAR
FUTURE THAT ADDRESSES SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES WILL BE HAPPY TO
RECONSIDER BUT FOR TODAY- I
BELIEVE I'LL BE LAYING OFF. ALI
YOU JUST YOU WON'T DO THAT NOW
ARE YOU WANT TO. ADDRESS IT IN
YOUR CLOTHES ALL ADDRESSING THE
CLOSING BUT I DO HAVE A
RESPONSE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KOREA. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. OKAY I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM OUR LEADER FOR
AUTHORING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND I'M
PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR. I'M
PROUD TO BE FROM THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES AND UNDERSTAND THAT
US URBAN LEGISLATORS HAVE A LOT
TO DEAL WITH WHEN IT COMES TO
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS AND I
DO HAVE TO SAY. THAT I WAS A CO
AUTHOR PRIOR TO THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN ON THE BILL THAT REMOVES
THE CORPORATE TAX WHICH I
BELIEVE MADE THE BILL STRONGER.
I'M SADDENED THAT IT'S NO
LONGER THERE I WAS SUPPORT OF
THEN I WOULD HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTIVE NOW OF IT. HOWEVER I
DO RECOGNIZE THAT IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE MUST
COME TO THE TABLE READYTO
NEGOTIATE AND SOMETIMES THAT
MEANS- MAKING. INCREDIBLY HARD
CHOICES ABOUT HOW TO MOVE THE
BILL FORWARD AND WE CAN ALLOW
THE PERFECT BE THE ENEMY OF THE
GOOD. THIS IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION- WHICH IS SO
NEEDED TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
I WANT. TO SHOW JUST A COUPLE
OF THINGS. AS A CHAIR BUT JUST
A- AND SHARE WITH YOU. THAT IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN THE STATE MADE
AN INVESTMENT OF FOUR POINT
THREE BILLION. FOR PROJECT ROOM
KEY. PUNKY IN IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL. THERE'S AN
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE
BILLION WITH A B. AN ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THESE EFFORTS WHICH
WE KNOW ARE INCREDIBLY
NECESSARY. EARLIER THIS YEAR IN
JANUARY I CHAIRED A JOINT
BUDGET HEARING WITH THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE AND
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- REPORT. WHICH WAS VERY
INSIGHTFUL AND HAPPY TO SHARE
WITH ALL OF YOU HERE- I'M GOING
TO TWEET IT OUT SO THAT FOLKS
WHO ARE LISTENING FOR
SUPPORTING HER SIMPLY WANT TO
KNOW MORE ABOUT- THIS
PARTICULAR ANALYSIS. CAN ALSO
HAVE IT IN IF THOSE THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN LEARNING MORE.
THE REPORT THE REPORT DISCLOSES
OF MANY THINGS THAT WE ALREADY
KNOW CALIFORNIA'S BEEN MORE IN
HOUSING THAT THE REST OF THE
NATION CALIFORNIANS SPEND A
LARGER SHARE OF THEIR INCOME ON
RENT. THAN HOUSEHOLDS IN THE
REST OF THE NATION AT EVERY
QUARTER. LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
FACE THE HIGHEST RISK OF
HOUSING INSTABILITY AND
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA.
AROUND TWO POINT FIVE. MILLION
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS SPEND
MORE THAN 30% OF THEIR INCOMES
ON HOUSING. OVER ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION LOW INCOME RENTERS FACE-EVEN MORE DIRE COST PRESSURES
SPENDING MORE THAN HALF OF
THEIR INCOME. ON HOUSING. IN
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY OVER
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND PEOPLE IN L.
A. COUNTY ALONE OR EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THAT'S NEARLY 13%
INCREASE FROM TWENTY NINETEEN.
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES WHICH
I'M PROUD TO REPRESENT AS YOU
ARE. HAS EXPERIENCED A SIXTY
PER 16% INCREASE IN ITS
HOMELESSNESS. HOMELESS
POPULATION. RISING IT TO ABOUT
FORTY ONE THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS-
THERE'S A LOT MORE DATA IN THIS
REPORT. EVERY IN TWENTY IN
TWENTY NINETEEN ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA WERE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS TWENTY POINT
TWENTY SEVEN PERCENT. OF THE
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION IN THE
NATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THERE WAS A 16%
INCREASE. BETWEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN.
72% OF CALIFORNIA HOMELESSNESS
POPULATION IS ON SHALL. 65% OF
THE POPULATION THAT IS HOMELESS
IS MALE 23% OF CALIFORNIA
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION IS
SEVERELY. MENTALLY ILL. AND
NEED RESOURCES IN ADDITION TO
WAT'S CURRENTLY BEING PROVIDED
17% OF CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION HAS A
CHRONIC SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDER. 15% OF CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESSNESS POPULATIONS
INCLUDES INCLUDES FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN. 8% OF CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION AS
UNACCOMPANIED YOUTH UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY FOUR. BETWEEN
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY NINETEEN. THE ONLY
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION
INCREASED BY 13% AND- OVERALL
27% OF CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION IS
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS. I CHERYL
THAT BECAUSE THAT'S THE REALITY
OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING ON THE
GROUND ACROSS THE STATE. I WANT
TO ADDRESS ONE MAJOR ISSUE ON
DATA THAT HAS BEEN ASKED- BY.
OUR COLLEAGUES. AGAIN IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY AND THE EARLY
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY HEARING
THAT I CHAIRED. SECRETARY LOOT
LOW TO THISCUSTOMER TO MEET
ITS WITH THE BUSINESS CONSUMER%
SERVICES AND HOUSING AGENCY
PRESENTED- SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN MISSING AND THAT WE HAVE
ALL BEEN ASKING FOR AND THAT'S
THE COLLECTION OF DATA. THE
HOMELESSNESS DATA INTEGRATION
SYSTEM. ALSO KNOWN AS H. D. I.
S. WHEN LIVE THIS PAST WEEK. I
WOULD ALLOW THE STATE TO ACCESS
AND COMPILE STANDARDIZED DATA
COLLECTED BY THE CONTINUUM'S OF
CARE. WHICH PROVIDES
INFORMATION ABOUT THE DELIVERY.
OF HOMELESS SERVICES ACROSS THE
STATE THE SYSTEM DID NOT EXIST
BEFORE. IT'S BEEN IN THE MAKING
FOR A FEW YEARS NOW IT JUST
WENT LIVE. ALL OF YOUR OFFICES
SHOULD HAVE RECEIVED. AN
INVITATION TO REVIEW THE
SYSTEM. SO WE CAN START
THINKING ABOUT HOW DO WE
COLLECT DATA. HOW DO WE
IMPLEMENT DATA AND HOW DO WE
USE THE DATA TO ENSURE. THAT
THE FUNDING RESOURCES THAT
WE'RE PUTTING TOGETHER ACTUALLY
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
AND PEOPLE ARE GETTING.
ASSISTANCE IF ANY OF YOU NEED
ADDITIONAL HELP WITH GETTING
THAT I'M HAPPY TO HELP. WITH
THAT PROCESS I WILL BE GOING
THROUGH THAT TRAINING MYSELF
BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE THE
SYSTEM. RIGHT THE SYSTEM WITH A
DOT LIVES THAT'S NEW NEVER BEEN
DONE BEFORE THAT'S NOW COME TO
LIFE. SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
SAY OKAY WE'RE PUTTING ALL
THESE RESOURCES ARE PASSING
IMPORTANT PIECES O
LEGISLATION. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
AND HOW THE HARD EARNED. TAX
DOLLARS OF CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ARE GOING INTO PROGRAMS THAT
EVENTUALLY AND HOPEFULLY HELP
US GT OUT OF THIS CRISIS SO
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD
WORK IN YOUR COMMITMENT ON
THIS. I WOULD HAVE VOTED FOR
THE PREVIOUS BILL VOTING HAPPY
TO BE VOTING FOR THIS BILL NOW.
AND WHAT WANT TO BE HELPFUL TO
YOU AS A COOPER TO THE BILL TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT MOVES
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD BE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AT AND I THINK
YOU KNOW SOMEONE RIVAS FOR
INTRODUCING THIS LEGISLATION I
REMEMBER SPEAKING WITH YOU
MONTHS AGO IT FEELS LIKE YEARS
AGO ACTUALLY THE THAT IN THE
TIME IT'S PAST- WE'RE USE-
SHARED WITH ME YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU WANT TO DO WITH THIS BILL I
YOU'VE DONE IT WITH A LOT OF
MEMBERS HAVE TAKEN THAT
FEEDBACK- AND BROUGHT THIS
FORWARD. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE ON YOU KNOW WORKING
WITH US IN EDUCATING US AND YOU
THANKS ME FOR MINE- BUT I JUST
REALLY CREDIT YOU FOR YOUR
DILIGENCE AND FOLLOW THROUGH
AND KEEPING IN TOUCH WITH US
ABOUT HOW YOU KNOW WHAT WE
CARED ABOUT HOW HE CARED AND
HOW WE THOUGHT ABOUT THE BILL-
IT'S I WAS IMPRESSED BY IT AND
ALSO TOUCHED BY. THE
AUTHENTICITY OF- HOW MUCH YOU
CARE ABOUT THIS ISSUE IS NOT
JUST ANOTHER BILL SO ANYONE
WOULD BE REALLY HAPPY TO HAVE
YOU AUTHORED A BILL FOR AN
ISSUE THAT THEY CARE A LOT
ABOUT- AND I'M GONNA SUPPORT
YOUR BILL SO LET'S JUST GET
THAT OUT OF THE WAY. SO I
REALLY THOUGHT- BECAUSE AS
BROADLY AND AS IS
PHILOSOPHICALLY. AS I COULD
ABOUT. HOW WE TAX IN IN WHAT WE
TAX WHEN HE FIRST PRESENTED
THIS TO ME IN THERE BUT A LOT
OF TALK ABOUT. ITS CONFORMITY
ALWAYS GOOD. IS NOW A RIGHT
TIME TO RAISE TAXES. AND THIS
IS JUST THE WEIRDEST OF TIMES.
AND IT'S A IT'S A REALLY-
AWKWARD TIME. IF YOU THINK
ABOUT ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCES SO
WE HAVE THIS EXTRAORDINARY-
EVENT OCCURRING WHERE WE DON'T
KNOW HOW IT'S GOING TO SHAKE
OUT AND AFFECT PEOPLE- YOU KNOW
I THINK TWELVE MONTHS AGO WE
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN WE PASSED A BUDGET THAT
WE THOUGHT THIS GUY WAS GOING
TO FALL- BUT IN FACT. WHAT WE
SAW WAS THAT THE VERY
WEALTHIEST AND MOST AFFLUENT
DID EXTRAORDINARILY WELL- THE
ECONOMY DID NOT CRATER EXCEPT
IF YOU ARE THE WORKING POOR.
THAT THEY THEY WERE THE ONES
WHO WERE HURT- THE WORST- AND
THE MOST. AND SO IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT CONFORMITY ON.
CORPORATIONS HIDING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS PROFITABLE CORPORATIONS
HIDING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OVERSEAS. THIS IS THIS IS NOT A
CAST OF CHARACTERS THAT I'M
FEELING. GUILTY ABOUT RAISING
TAXES ON NO PUN INTENDED AND-
AND IN IT AND IT STRIKES ME
THAT GUILTY WAS A BIPARTISAN
COMPROMISE IN WASHINGTON- LED
BY REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT THAT
CHAMPIONED YOU KNOW BIG
BUSINESS AND- AND THOUGHT IT
WAS APPROPRIATE TO RAISES TAXES
SO- I DON'T FIND IT
INAPPROPRIATE FOR CALIFORNIA.
TO DO THE SAME THING. I THINK
IT IS INTERESTING THAT WE HAVE
NEVER HAD MORE REVENUE THAN WE
DO RIGHT NOW- AND THAT IS
BECAUSE WELL OUR TAX SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA IS INCREDIBLY FLAWED
PARTICULARLY IN TRULY BAD
TIMES. THIS TRULY BAD TIME WE
TAX THE RIGHT PEOPLE WE TAX THE
ONES WHO DID THE BEST WITH THE
STOCK MARKET THAT HAS
SKYROCKETED- AND CORPORATIONS
THAT HAVE DONE VERY WELL
CALIFORNIA DOES WELL AND SO
WHEN I LOOKED AT WHAT WOULD WE
DO IF WE RAISED THE GUILTY TAX.
THAT DIED THAT WHAT COULD WE DO
FOR CALIFORNIANS IN ONE PLACE
WHERE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DID RAISE TAXES WAS ON- THE
DEDUCTION FOR STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES AND WOULD IT WOULD BE
GREAT TO BE ABLE TO RAISE
TAXES. ON ON THE CORPORATIONS
THAT DID THE BEST AND THEN
OFFSET THOSE WHO HAD OF A BIRD
HIGHER BURDEN PLACED ON THEM-
BUT YOU FOUND A MORE IMPORTANT
THING TO SPEND THAT MONEY ON.
SO YOU HOMELESSNESS IS A HIGHER
ORDER NEED. AND THAT'S NOT
SAYING THAT WE'RE NOT SPENDING
MONEY ON THAT BUT IF WE DIDN'T
SPEND MONEY ON THAT WHAT WITH
THE MASS BE. IN OUR STATE. AND
THEY'RE THEY'RE ALL
CALIFORNIANS THEY'RE NOT.
ANGELENOS STATE THEY'RE NOT
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN THE STICKS
SIR SKID ROW OR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY OR THE COAST FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WE NEED TO CARE
ABOUT EVERYONE. IS THERE'S NO
TRIBALISM HERE. AND IF THERE IS
IT'S WRONG. THE AND SO WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT. WHAT'S THE
TIPPING POINT IN CALIFORNIA IS
IT HIGHER TAXES DID WE RAISE
THEM TOO HIGH. OR IS THE
QUALITY OF LIFE SO BAD THAT WE
ARE FREE TO STEP OUTSIDE OUR
DOOR. THAT'S THE TIPPING POINT.
CORPORATIONS AREN'T FLEEING
CALIFORNIA THERE IS NO MASS
EXODUS. IS THE WORKING POOR WHO
ARE TRYING TO FIND A WAY OUT.
AS THE MAYBE THE MIDDLE CLASS
THAT'S SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT.
MAYBE WE'RE NOT CARING FOR
PEOPLE ENOUGH IN CALIFORNIA AND
THIS IS IN A PLACE THAT I WANT
TO RAISE MY FAMILY. ANY LONGER.
OR CAN'T FIND HOUSING THAT'S
AFFORDABLE. AND SO WHEN WE FREE
OUR- OUR ITIES OR SMALL TOWNS
BECAUSE THERE ARE HOMELESS
PEOPLE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN GREAT
NEED. THAT THE SOCIAL SAFETY
NET IS NOT STRONG ENOUGH. EVEN
WHILE THE WEALTHIEST HAVE NEVER
BEEN RICHER. EVEN ALL THE
CORPORATIONS HAVE NEVER BEEN
MORE SUCCESSFUL. THAT THERE ARE
STILL MORE CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
HURTING. VISIBLY NOT JUST IN
HIDING. BUT ACTUALLY IN HIDING
BUT THAT YOU CAN'T SEE. THAT
THAT WE KNOW THERE ARE PROBLEMS
IN SOCIETY SO WE NEED TO
REDOUBLE OUR EFFORTS WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE MAKING THE
BEST INVESTMENTS THAT IS
HAPPENING CONTINUALLY. I AM NOT
I'M PROUD TO SAY YOU KNOW PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC AT LEAST IN MY
HOME COUNTY ARE HOMELESS RATES
WENT DOWN. ON AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THOSE WILL BE IN THE
FUTURE BECAUSE OUR HEAD COUNTS
YOU KNOW I HAVE NOT BEEN THE
SAME SINCE THE PANDEMIC AND WE
KNOW THAT THE PROBLEM IS.
EXTRAORDINARILY SEVERE. BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT WHEN I WAS ALSO
THINKING ABOUT THIS HOUSING
ALSO IN THE BUSINESS GROUPS
THAT HAVE WEIGHED IN AGAINST
THIS. THEY'RE REALLY PROUD TO
STAND UP FOR THEIR MEMBERS. WHO
AGAIN ARE ARE MAKING A PROFIT.
PROBABLY NEVER BEEN AS GOOD FOR
THEM AS A IT AS IT EVER HAS
BEEN- AS IT IS TODAY. AND IF
YOU IF THEY SAY THEY REALLY DO
CARE ABOUT HOUSING BECAUSE
YOU'RE ALL FOR ALL THE HOUSING
BILLS. WHEN EVERYONE ELSE IS
PAYING FOR IT. THEY'RE ALL FOR
THE HOUSING BILLS WHEN THERE'S
A BOND ON THE BALLOT WE'RE
PAYING BACK THAT BOND IS THE
CROWD OUT. SOCIAL SERVICE
SPENDING COULD YOU KNOW WE GOT
TO PAY INTEREST SOMEONE THAT WE
GOTTA PAY PRINCE WILL BACK ON
THOSE BONDS. THEY'RE ALL FOR IT
WHEN IT COMES OUT HOUSE OUT
OTHER SPENDING. IN THE BUDGET.
THEY'RE NOT FOR IT WHEN THEY'RE
MEMBERS WHO PAY THEIR SALARIES.
DON'T WANT. TO BUT THERE
MEMBERS ARE DOING REALLY WELL
SO IF YOU REALLY CARE ABOUT
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS YOU
SHOULD CARE ABOUT IT WHEN
YOU'RE ASKED TO CHIP IN. YOU
SHOULDN'T ONLY TO SAY YOU
SUPPORT. MORE BONDS THAT ARE
GONNA SQUEEZE OUT THE SPENDING
THAT ARE CAN ALSO PROVIDE THE
SOLUTIONS SO I LOOK FOR TO
VOTING AYE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE DOCTOR CORD AND THEN
THE VICE CHAIR. YES I'LL JUST-
DISAGREE WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR MERCED- LOOK THIS
REALLY ISN'T A TAX INCREASE
THIS ISN'T. THIS IS TRYING TO
DO THE SAME THING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DID. WHICH IS TO
TAKE MONIES THAT SHOULDN'T BE
HIDDEN ABROAD AND MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE. ALLOCATED WHERE
THEY WORK WHICH IS IN
CALIFORNIA. SO THAT'S ONE POINT
THE OTHER POINT IS IT REALLY
DOES COST. BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO MAKE UP
FOR THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT
HASN'T BEEN BUILT. AND FURTHER
SINCE A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN ON THE STREET FOR A
VERY LONG TIME. THEY NEED
SOCIAL SERVICES SUPPORT IT'D
JUST GET USED TO PAYING RENT
TEN. YOU KNOW HOW HAVING A HOME
IN TREATING IT WELL. THIS WAS
NOT DONE. IN THE HOUSING
PROGRAMS THAT WE SAW IN THE
FORTIES FIFTIES AND SIXTIES.
AND THOSE PLACES BECAME
UNACCEPTABLE- SO WE'RE GOING TO
NEED BOTH THE HOUSING AND THE
SUPPORT FOR THE PEOPLE IF WE DO
THIS WE CAN MAKE A REAL CHANGE
IN CALIFORNIA. BUT IT ISN'T
CHEAP AND FRANKLY THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IS A DROP IN
THE BUCKET COMPARED TO WHAT WE
HAVE TO SPEND. I WILL ALSO SAY
THAT THERE WERE CERTAIN
CERTAINLY THERE WERE PROBLEMS
WITH THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT WAS BUILT IN THE FORTIES
FIFTIES AND SIXTIES AND
SEVENTIES HOWEVER. AT LEAST WE
WERE BUILDING AT AND FRANKLY
THERE WAS LITTLE TO NO.
HOMELESSNESS AND CERTAINLY
EVERYONE COULD HAVE A HOME OVER
THEIR HEADS. WHEN REAGAN CAME
IN THE FIRST THING THAT WAS CUT
TO PAY FOR HIS TAXES WAS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WAS NEVER
REAL POPULAR BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TO PUT IT NEAR SOMEBODY. SO
ANYWAY WE STOP PAIN WE PROBABLY
SHOULD IF WE'D CONTINUED WITH
THE PROGRAMS WE HAD WE PROBABLY
WANT TO SPEND A TRILLION
DOLLARS BY NOW. OF WHICH A
HUNDRED BILLION WOULD HAVE GONE
TO CALIFORNIA AND THEN MAYBE WE
WOULDN'T HAVE HOMELESSNESS. SO
THIS IS A SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY
FOR YOU TO PROBLEM. BUT IT'LL
HOPEFULLY GET US THERE AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE REFORMS
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- FIRST I WANT
TO APPLAUD YOUR EFFORT. WE ALL
ON HERE KNOWS THERE'S A
HOMELESS PROBLEM WALK OUT THIS
CAPITAL YOU SEE IT WALK OUT MY
DOOR MY HOME YOU SEE IT WHAT TO
MY GROCERY STORE YOU'LL SEE IT
DRIVE DOWN THE STREET TO MY
CHILDREN'S SCHOOL YOU SEE IT.
THERE'S NO WHERE THE G. CANNOT
SEE AND WE DON'T WE ALL AGREED
THERE'S A PROBLEM. BUT HERE'S
MY CONCERN. WHAT THE PANDEMIC
YOUR LOVE WE'RE THERE'S AN
ESTIMATE ABOUT 40% OF
BUSINESSES SHUTTING DOWN IN
CALIFORNIA. WHETHER WE WON OR
ARE YOU A WE ARE PRO BUSINESS
AGAINST MRS I DON'T CARE. AT
THE END OF DAY BUSINESS COMES
WITH JOBS. JOBS ALLOW
CALIFORNIANS TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILY AND TO
BE ABLE TO. GET IT BECAUSE I
GET INTO THE MIDDLE CLASS AND
DO A LITTLE BETTER. LOOK I GREW
UP POOR I WAS ON WELFARE AND
FOOD STAMPS. MY FAMILY WE
DIDN'T SPEAK ANY ENGLISH WHEN
WE CAME HERE FROM THAILAND AS A
REFUGEE. I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE
TO HAVE TO WORK AT TEN YEARS
OLD TO CLEAN HOUSES JUST TO GET
MONEY TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
CLOTHES. OR SCHOOL SUPPLIES. I
KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE FOR MY
PARENTS HAVE TO FIGHT AND ARGUE
WHETHER WE'RE GETTING SOME GAS
FOR THEM TO GO WORK. FOR A
GALLON OF MILK FOR US FOR THE
WEEK. I'VE BEEN THERE I KNOW
IT. BUT WHAT I'VE SEEN THOUGH
IS THAT WE CONTINUE TO SHUT
DOWN AND PEOPLE BLAMING THE SO
CALLED CORPORATION. THAT'S SO
COOPER CORPORATION. THE ONE
THAT IS PAYING FORTY PERCENT.
47% OF OUR STATE BUDGET. THAT'S
THEIR INCOME THAT'S COMING IN
SO THE IDEA TO SAY THAT THEY
DON'T PAY. THEIR FAIR SHARE. WE
CAN ALWAYS ASK FOR MORE BUT
PLEASE DON'T SAY THEY DON'T PAY
THEIR FAIR SHARE. AND SECOND IF
WE KEEP ON SHUTTING THESE
BUSINESSES. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
MORE JOBS IN CALIFORNIA THE
HIGH PAYING JOBS. I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE OTHER JOBS.
NOT THE TOURISM JOB WHICH IS
GREAT JOBS BUT THEY'RE NOT HIGH
PAYING JOBS FOR FAMILY TO
PROVIDE FOR THEIR CHILDREN. WE
HAVE SPENT IN CALIFORNIA
THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS. IN
THE LAST THREE YEARS. I'M SORRY
IT HAS NOT HELPED AT ALL.
SOMEBODY PLEASE PROVIDE ME WITH
INFORMATION HOW THE MONEY WAS
SPENT I'M MORE THAN WILLING TO
SUPPORT. TO HELP EASE. THE
SITUATION. BUT MY CONSTITUENTS
ARE TELLING ME WELL WHAT DID
YOU DO WITH YOUR MONEY WHERE
DID IT GO. IT'S WORSE THAN IT I
MEAN EVEN IF IT'S WASN'T A
PANDEMIC IT'S STILL IT'S IT
ACTUALLY WAS IN IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. IT WAS
REALLY BAD ALREADY BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. OF COURSE IT'S GOTTEN
WORSE. BUT IT'S NOT HELPING
WHERE DID ALL THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS HAS GONE AND IS IT JUST.
ONE WATER INTO A GLASS IT'S
READY FULL OF PROBLEMS JUST
THROWING MONEY AWAY IS NOT
GOING TO WORK AND SO I DID I
MEAN. YOU KNOW WE CAN'T HAVE
ANYMORE BUSINESSES LEAVING THE
STATE AND WE CAN THAT WE I KNOW
THAT WE ALL HAVE A DIFFERENT.
ARGUMENTS WHY THEY'RE LEAVING.
BUT WE ARE JUST THEY'RE LEAVING
WHETHER WE WANT TO ARGUE WHY
THEY'RE LEAVING OR NOT THEY'RE
LEAVING. AND THOSE ARE ALL THE
MANUFACTURING JOBS THAT PACE
REALLY REALLY WELL. AND YET WE
HAVE SUCH A TERRIBLE TERRIBLE
PROBLEM OF HOMELESSNESS THAT'S
NOT GOING AWAY WITH PULLING IN
MORE MONEY. AND LIKE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID- FROM THE
RULE ERA IS THAT. WE NEED
COLLABORATION I HAVEN'T BEEN ON
THE COUNCIL HAVEN'T BEEN A
COUNTY SUPERVISOR HAVEN'T BEEN
ON THE SENATE AND NOW IN THE
ASSEMBLY. THERE'S NO THIS
COLLABORATION DOESN'T EXIST
WHEN IT COMES TO HOMELESS SUCH
SOLUTIONS. IT ANY LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT WE APPEAR HAVE OWN
IDEA ON BOTH SIDES I- HAS THEIR
OWN IDEA FROM THE RURAL VERSUS
URBAN HAS DIFFERENT IDEAS. IN
MY COUNTY- CENTRAL WEST ORANGE
COUNTY HAS A VERY DIFFERENT
IDEA THAN SELF ORANGE COUNTY.
THAT'S JUST REALITY SO ONE SIZE
DOESN'T FIT ALL. AND MORE MORE
MONEY IS NOT GOING TO GO AWAY.
ONE OF THE YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
MEMBER MENTIONED BY THE HOME
SHE TOLD THEM. IT'S A GREAT
IDEA GREAT PROGRAM. MY
UNDERSTAND IS AN ORANGE COUNTY.
ONLY ONE CITY APPLY FOR.
BECAUSE YOU CAN FIND HOTELS OR
MOTELS TO BE ABLE TO CONVERT IT.
YEAH I MEAN THE GREAT IDEAS BUT
ORANGE COUNTY MY UNDERSTAND HAS
ONLY ONE CITY. AS OF I THINK
LAST YEAR THAT ACTUALLY APPLY
FOR. IT'S NOT THAT WE DON'T
WANT IT IT'S THAT IT DOESN'T
WORK IN ORANGE COUNTY. SO YOU
CAN THROW MORE MONEY AT US OR
ANYONE ELSE IN THE STATE. I
DON'T SEE IT CHANGING AND IT'S
NOT HELPING AND SO. I APPLAUD
THE EFFORT AND I'M NOT YOU
KNOW. NOT SAY THAT I'M NOT HERE
TO HELP HOMELESSNESS PROBLEM. I
GO OUT EVERY YEAR FOR YOU KNOW
HOW DECADE. DOING THE COUNT. IN
THE EVENING- WE DONE LOTS OF
TASK FORCE WHEN I WAS ON THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
AND IT JUST IT. IT'S GOTTEN SO
BAD THE LAST FOUR FIVE YEARS.
AND WE PULL MORE MONEY THAN
WE'VE HAD. A DECADE AGO AND
IT'S NOT GOING AWAY IT'S GOTTEN
WORSE WE CAN'T EVEN STEP OUT OF
OUR HOUSE OR STEP DOWN THE
STREET OR EVEN. YOU KNOW IN THE
PARK AREA AND NOT BE AFRAID FOR
CHILDREN- AND SO YOU KNOW I
THINK THERE'S GOT TO BE BETTER
WAYS TO DO THIS AND- AND HOW DO
WE JUSTIFY TO OUR CONSTITUENT
WHEN. EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT THE
STATE'S CAN HAVE BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS SURPLUS.
WHEN IS. WHEN IS IT TIME TO
LOOK BACK AND HELP THE TAXPAYER
THE BUSINESSES WHO ARE CREATING
THESE HIGH PAYING JOBS. SO I
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORTS I WILL BE OPPOSING THE
THEM TODAY. FINGERPRINT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE HOMELESS AND
A POTENTIAL SOLUTION. HOWEVER
AYE SIR SURE A LOT OF THE SAME
CONCERNS OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO
JUST SPOKE SHARES OF FIRST OF
ALL WITH IN REGARDS TO HOMELESS
WE HAVE SPENT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS CHASING AFTER
DISSOLUTION. AND WE HAVEN'T
FOUND IT YET I WOULD LIKE US TO
FIND THE SOLUTION AND ONE OF
THE PROBLEMS IS BECAUSE THERE'S
SOME DIFFERENT FACETS OF
HOMELESS AND YOU CAN PRETTY
MUCH PUT IN FIVE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES. AND SOME OF THEM WE
JUST DON'T HAVE THE POLITICAL
WILL TO TAKE CARE OF IT- THE
MENTALLY ILL THE DRUG ABUSE AND
THOSE WE JUST DON'T HAVE THAT
CAPACITY. AND UNTIL WE DECIDE
WHAT WE WANT TO DO ABOUT THAT.
WE CAN THROW ALL THE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IT ALL OF THE YOU
KNOW THE VARIOUS AGENCIES THAT
THINK THEY'RE TRYING TO STEP UP
AND HELP THESE FOLKS. THEY WANT
BUT IF. WE HAVE IF WE DON'T IF
WE DON'T SOLVE THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO SOLVE THAT PROBLEM BY
GIVING THEM HOUSES OR OR TRYING
TO PAY RENT FOR THEM- THEY'RE
STILL GOING TO BE OUT THERE.
THE HOMELESS ISSUE IN OUR
REGION HAS GOTTEN WORSE. AND
AND IT'S NOT AS VISIBLE- YOU
KNOW PEOPLE THOUGHT IT WAS
GETTING BETTER BUT NOW THEY
JUST LEARNED HOW TO HIDE
BETTER. AND SO THAT YOU KNOW I
JUST DON'T SEE THAT AS BEING A
GOOD REASON TO RAISE TAXES ON
SOMEBODY TO PAY FOR SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE NO IDEA WHETHER.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
IT BETTER OR NOT- I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE A DIFFERENT. A DIFFERENT
APPROACH WITH THE WITH THE
COSTS FOR HOMELESS IS. THIS IS
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO THIS IS HOW
MUCH IT WILL COST AND THIS IS
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO FIND THE
MONEY TO DO IT. ARE IN THIS
PARTICULAR SITUATION I HAVE
GRAVE CONCERNS. ABOUT THE
RAISING OF AGAIN- IT GOING
AFTER THOSE CORPORATIONS.
BECAUSE THERE IS THERE IS SOME
LOSS THERE IS SOME BLEEDING IN
CALIFORNIA OF SOME PRETTY BIG
CORPORATIONS THAT HAVE LEFT BUT
THE BIGGER QUESTION THERE THE
BIGGER ISSUE IS WE ALSO WANT
CORPORATIONS TO COME HERE IT'S
HARD TO LEAVE IT REALLY IS IT'S
HARD FOR BUSINESSES SET UP AND
BE HERE FOR FIFTY YEARS AND
THEN SAY YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
PACKING UP WE'RE LEAVING. BUT
IT'S NOT REALLY HARD FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE CONSIDERING WHERE THEY
WANT TO GROW THEIR BUSINESS
WHERE THEY WANT TO EMPLOY
PEOPLE. TO SAY YOU KNOW WHAT
THAT PLACE IS OFF LIMITS WE
JUST CAN'T AFFORD IT. AND
THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF
BUSINESSES. IN THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WORLD IN A LOT OF
THE CITIES AROUND. THAT'S A
WERE COMING ACROSS PEOPLE WHO
SAY WE ABSOLUTELY ARE NOT GOING
TO DO BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS IS JUST ONE MORE OF
THOSE THINGS THAT I FEEL LIKE
IS CAUSING THAT ENVIRONMENT. SO
SO EASY YEAH I'M I'M I NEED TO
OPPOSE THIS- BECAUSE I- YEAH I
DO RECOGNIZE THAT THE PROBLEM
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO SOLVE AND
I LOVED IT. I HOPE SOMEDAY WE
CAN FIGURE IT OUT. WE HAVEN'T
DONE IT IN THE TEN YEARS OR
THAT I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN
TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS STUFF-
BUT- I CAN'T KEEP CHASING
BUSINESSES OUT HERE. THOSE JOBS
ARE CRUCIAL TO SOLVING PART OF
THAT HOMELESS ISSUE. ENOUGH AND
THAT'S THE PART. WHERE THE
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO WORK. AND
WHO CAN BE EMPLOYED AND NOW CAN
AFFORD TO MAKE A HOUSE. PAYMENT
CAN ACTUALLY DO THAT. RIGHT NOW
THEY CAN'T AND IF WE DON'T GET
MORE JOBS HERE FOR THEM THEY'LL
NEVER BE ABLE TO DO THAT WILL
NEVER SOLVE THAT PROBLEM
EITHER. SO THAT'S WHERE I'M
KIND OF COMING FROM MONEY I
APPRECIATE. YOUR EFFORTS. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO HELPING BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU. I THINK I'M LAST.
FIRST I WANT TO THINK THE
AUTHOR I KNOW THAT YOU HAD TO
HEAR A LOT HERE AND I KNOW THAT
WE HAVE MAIS MYSELF OUR OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF AND- AND YOU
AND YOUR COALITION OF I THINK
ABOUT EIGHTEEN GROUPS- HAVE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME TALKING
ABOUT THIS I THINK THAT WE DID
OUR BEST TO PREPARE YOU FOR
WHAT WAS PROBABLY GOING TO BE
SAID TODAY AND SOME OF THE
POSITIVES AND CONCERNS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE EXPRESSED
TODAY. I REALIZE OUR GUEST
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO WAS
FINE WITH THE WAY THE BILL WAS
BEFORE BUT I THINK THAT YOU SEE
WHY WE HAVE THE AMENDMENTS WE
DID FOR CLARIFYING PURPOSES- I
CAN'T REMEMBER WHO SAID IT BUT
SOMEONE SAID THAT THE CORPORATE
TAX ACCOUNTS 440% IT'S 10% OF
OUR BUDGET BUT- JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT WERE DEALING WITH
ACTUAL FACTS HERE- SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS I
KNOW IT'S BEEN A LOT AND YOU
HAVE BEEN VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT
THIS ISSUE I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT
COLLABORATION AND THAT THERE'S
NO CENTRAL HUB AND I KNOW YOU
HAVE WORKED SO HARD ON THAT. IN
THE PAST AND THAT IS NOT THIS
BILL SO I WANT TO CLARIFY A LOT
OF THINGS THAT WE'RE SECOND
TIER TODAY HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH THIS ACTUAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND IS IN FRONT OF
US- THAT BEING SAID OBVIOUSLY I
HAVE THE SAME CONCERNS- THAT
MANY HAVE EXPRESSED IN THAT IS
MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT THERE'S
MEANS TEST FOR ALL THESE
PROGRAMS THAT DO GET THESE
FUNDS- BUT WITH THAT I THINK
THAT WE'VE COME UP WITH A
REALLY BALANCED OPTION- TWO
SEATS TO HELP PEOPLE WHO ARE
DOING THEIR BEST AND WHO ARE TO
HAVE SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS RIGHT.
NOW FOR GETTING PEOPLE OFF THE
STREETS. YES LIVING IN URBAN.
IS VERY DIFFICULT AS A MEMBER
FROM URBAN COMMUNITY I KNOW HOW
HARD IT IS- WE HAVE STRUGGLED.
WE HAVE STRUGGLE TO ALLEVIATE
THIS PROBLEM AND NO MONEY IS
NOT GOING TO BE THE ONLY THING
TO FIX IT. BUT I THINK THIS IS
ONE SMALL STEP IN THE DIRECTION
OF MAKING THINGS A LITTLE BIT
BETTER FOR THOSE YOUNG KIDS
THAT LIVE ON THE STREET RIGHT
NOW WHO DON'T GET A SECOND
CHANCE OF BEING AND KIDS. WITH
THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
INTO YOUR COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH ME. AND TO. THE DIVERSE
COALITION THAT IS BEHIND THIS
BILL- FROM ALL PARTS OF THE
STATE- YOU KNOW. THIS
DISCUSSION HAS. BEEN GREAT FOR
ME BECAUSE- ALL OF YOU SPOKE.
EVERY MEMBER. OF THIS
COMMITTEE. REQUESTED TO SPEAK
AND TO COMMENT BECAUSE- ONE
THING IS WE- ALL. CARE ABOUT
SOLVING THIS CRISIS- ALL OF
YOU. I COULD HEAR IT. IN YOUR
COMMENTS HOW PASSIONATE. YOU
ARE. ABOUT GETTING TO A
SOLUTION- AND WHETHER YOU'RE
FROM. A RURAL AREA. URBAN AREA.
SUBURBAN AREA THE INLAND
EMPIRE. THE BAY AREA. WE ALL
CARE IT'S- A PROBLEM. THAT HAS
UNFORTUNATELY. DEVASTATED ALL
PARTS OF THE STATE. AND WHILE I
AM PROUD. TO BE AN LA
LEGISLATOR. RIGHT I KNOW THAT
THIS IS NOT JUST AN ALLEY
PROBLEM. AND WHEN I. DEVELOP
THIS BILL AND LISTEN TO ALL OF
YOU FOR FEEDBACK AND MADE THE
AMENDMENTS. BASED ON YOUR
REQUESTS. IT WAS BECAUSE IT HAS
TO WORK FOR ALL OF US ACROSS
THE STATE. RIGHT AND ONE THING.
THAT HAS BEEN MISSING. IN
HOMELESSNESS IS AN ON GOING
FUNDING SOURCE. THAT DOESN'T
RELY. ON THE FISCAL HEALTH OF
THE GENERAL FUND. RIGHT BECAUSE
WHILE WE'RE DOING WELL THIS
YEAR AND SEVERAL OF YOU
MENTIONED AND I AGREE. ON THAT
IS NOT ALWAYS THE CASE THAT
MANY OF YOU HAVE SERVED MUCH
LONGER THAN I HAVE. IN THE
LEGISLATURE. AND WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING TO DO. IS TO COME. TO
A FEDERAL TAX. THAT WAS
IMPLEMENTED. DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION. A REPUBLICAN.
PRESIDENT CAME UP WITH THIS TAX
I DON'T INVENTED ARE COLD
CHINDIT. WE ARE CONFORMING JUST
LIKE WE DID IN TWENTY NINETEEN
WHEN WE MOST OF US VOTED FOR AB
NINETY ONE LED BY OUR CHAIR-
THAT CONFORMS. IN ORDER TO FIND
THE KELLY I. T. C. FOR OUR
NEEDY FAMILIES THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING TODAY. AND I THINK
WHILE- I KNOW THERE WAS A LOT
OF CRITICISM ON THIS REVENUE
SOURCE- I THINK THE BEST THING
IS THAT IT DOES NOT RELY ON THE
GENERAL FUND. TO IT'S SOMETHING
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DID
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN- AND ALSO
IT ONLY AFFECTS A SMALL NUMBER
OF LARGE MULTINATIONAL
COMPANIES THAT HAVE ATTEMPTED
TO AVOID TAXES BY SHIFTING
PROFITS OVERSEAS. IT'S VERY
TARGETED RATE I'M LIKE I SAID I
DID NOT INVENT THIS OF THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WAS PASSED UNDER
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
NOW THIS IS A CHANCE TO CATCH
UP FOR CALIFORNIA TO COME
FORWARD TO IT. AND USE THAT
REVENUE. FOR TO TARGET
HOMELESSNESS AND I KNOW A LOT
OF US MENTIONED THAT WE'VE
SPENT X. AMOUNT OF MONEY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
HOMELESSNESS AND IT HASN'T
WORKED. BUT I HAVE VISITED.
PLACES WHERE IT HAS WORKED
WHERE PEOPLE ARE BEING HOUSE
AND WE DON'T SEE THEM BECAUSE
NOW THEIR HOUSE. THEY'RE
GETTING THE SERVICES THEY NEED
RIGHT I'M FORTY THE PROBLEM
CONTINUES TO GROW AND IT IS
STILL VISIBLE. RIGHT BUT THAT
MONEY HAS BEEN USED TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO HOUSE PEOPLE TO
HELP CHILDRENAND FAMILIES THAT
DID NOT HAVE A STABLE HOME IN
OUR STATE. WHERE CORPORATIONS
CONTINUE TO THRIVE AND I
SUPPORT THAT I SUPPORT GOOD
JOBS I HAVE SERVED ON THIS
COMMITTEE- FOR ALMOST THREE
YEARS AND I HAVE SUPPORTED TAX
CREDITS THAT BRING JOBS TO ALL
OF OUR CMMUNITIES. RIGHT BUT
THIS TAX THIS SPECIFIC TAX. OF
IT JUST TARGETS A SMALL NUMBER
IT DOES NOT TARGET SMALL
BUSINESSES- IF YOU DON'T HAVE
FOREIGN ASSETS. THAT CORP THOSE
CORPORATIONS ARE NOT AFFECTED
RIGHT IT'S VERY TARGETED AND I
THINK. OF WE LIKE I SAID WE LL
SHARE THE PASSION FOR
HOMELESSNESS SO DO ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS YOU KNOW THIS
ISSUE POLLS AT THE TOP WHEN YOU
PULL OR VOTERS THIS IS WHAT
THEY WANT US TO DO. WHEN WE
COME EVERY WEEK TO SACRAMENTO.
AND WHAT I HEARD TODAY. FROM
ALL OF YOU AND ALL OF YOU SPOKE
I'VE NEVER PRESENTED TO
COMMITTEE WORK EVERY MEMBER HOW
TO COMMENT. ON ONE OF MY BILLS
OF AND SO I'M VERY HONORED THAT
YOU DID BECAUSE IT SHOWS THAT
WE ALL WANT TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION. AND SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU I EVEN THOSE OF YOU
THAT ARE NOT SUPPORTING. YOU
KNOW I'M HEARING YOU I'M
HEARING YOUR PASSION TO WANT TO
WORK AND I WELCOME YOU TO BE
PART OF THIS COALITION. THIS
BILL IS NOT GOING TO SOLVE IT
ALL. BUT LIKE I SAID THERE ARE
OTHER PROPOSALS. OUT THERE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS
SUPPORTING THAT OTHER MEMBERS
HAVE SUPPORTED AND I ENCOURAGE
ALL OF US. TO JOIN THEM AND TO
GIVE THEM THAT FEEDBACK BECAUSE
SOMETIMES WE DON'T DO THAT
WE'RE ALL BUSY. BUT WE ALL WANT
TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM. AND
THAT'S WHY I DECIDED TO WORK
WITH THIS COALITION BECAUSE
THEY HAD A SOLUTION. AND I
THINK. THIS IS PART OF THE
SOLUTION. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. WE HAD A MOTION AND A
SECOND MISTER MOON WHICH
CULTURAL. BURKE HI BURKE OKAY
WHEN. WINDOW THREE. GRANO
GRAYSON GRAYSON I LEVINE LEVINE
I CARILLO RELY MULLIN LONG
ISLAND ICED TEA TREE NORRIS.
OKAY OF PETRIE-NORRIS NOT
VOTING. I'M SORRY EXCUSE ME
PETRIE-NORRIS NEL QUIRK HI
KIRKA RIVAS HI RIVAS I'D SAY
ARE TOP NOW CERTAIN L. SEVEN TO
FOUR MA'AM. THAT'S SEVEN TO FOR
YOUR BILL IS OUT ALSO
TRANSPORTATION IS CLOSING SO
THEY SIT HER DOWN AND IT'S TO
DO PASSED A HOUSING AND THAT TO
DO PASSED THE HOUSING. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR MULTI
TASKING HERE TODAY. ALL RIGHT I
DON'T SEE SANTIAGO AND ARTWORK
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT YOU
CAN DO IT FROM THERE IF YOU'D
LIKE. MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I WILL ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AMENDMENT
TO STATED IN THE ANALYSIS PAGE
THREE ITEMS B. C. D. BELIEVE
THAT TAKES CARE OF- EVERYTHING
THAT WAS ASKED FOR- IF WE GET
THE POINT HERE IS WE'RE TRYING
TO GET. RESEARCH DONE FOR WHAT
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT A LITTLE
WHILE AGO WHICH IS
UNDERSTANDING IF THE PROGRAMS
WE HAVE TO GET PEOPLE OUT OF
POVERTY REALLY WORK. AND FOR
THAT WERE REQUIRED TO TAKE A
LOOK AT ALL SORTS OF DATA
INCLUDING THE TAX DATA. IN THIS
CASE- TAKE IT WE'VE TECH WE
HAVE TAKEN THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO ASSURE THAT THIS TAX
DATA DOES NOT. CONTAIN
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION THAT EVEN IF THEY
GOT IT BY ACCIDENT THEY CAN'T
GIVE IT OUT. AND IN ADDITION
IT'S ONLY STATE TAX RECORDS NOT
FEDERAL SO IT'S GOT THAT IS
ADDED INTO DATA FROM MANY OTHER
SOURCES- IT DOESN'T REQUIRE THE
TAX BOARD TO GIVE THE- THE
INFORMATION OUT IT SIMPLY
ALLOWS THEM TO DO IT ALLOWS
THEM TO CHARGE- ANY. NECESSARY
COSTS SO THAT'S- THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE BUT THE BIG THING IS WE
NEED TO KNOW IF PRESIDENT
PROGRAMS ARE WORKING. AND I
HAVE TODAY- JAMIE AUSTIN FROM
THE TIPPING POINT COMMUNITY WHO
WILL SPEAK TO THIS. OKAY WE
HAVE A MODERATOR WE HAVE A G.
ME AUSTIN OF TIPPING POINT
COMMUNITY ON THE LINE WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND WITHOUT
WORK. GOOD GAP A BIGGER DICK.
OCULAR MEMBERS- JAMIE OFTEN THE
POINT COMMUNITY I THINK YOU
THOUSAND FIVE WE'VE INVESTED
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED MILLION
AND SOLUTION TO FIGHT POVERTY
IN THE BAY AREA AND THE LAST
TWO YEARS WE'VE WORKED TO
INCREASE THE UPTAKE OF
CALIFORNIA'S EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT. ARE
CURRENTLY RESEARCHERS CAN USE
DATA FROM THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD ONLY TO SAY TOPICS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
RESPECTIVE DEPARTMENT MISSION
BUT WE THINK WE CAN LEARN A LOT
MORE FROM THE DATA AFTER THIS
BILL AGENCIES AND RETAIN
DISCRETION ABOUT WHICH PROJECTS
TO APPROVED. AND IN FACT THE
BILL WOULD GIVE AGENCIES MORE
DISCRETION TO ALLOW RESEARCHERS
TO EXPLORE A RANGE OF POVERTY
RELATED STUDIES AB SO WE MIGHT
LEARN THINGS LIKE THE IMPACT OF
OUR TAX CREDIT ON VARIOUS-
HEALTH OUTCOMES WE COULD GAUGE
THE IMPACT OF JOB LOSS ON
FAMILY PROPERTY AND ECONOMIC
WELL BEING. WE CAN EXAMINE
PARTICIPATION IN THE STATE PAGE
NOT PROGRAM TO UNDERSTAND THE
EXTENT TO WHICH THOSE WHO ARE
ENROLLED OR ELIGIBLE FOR ONE
SERVICE ARE ACCESSING OTHER
IMPORTANT SERVICES. AND WE
THINK THESE ARE IMPORTANT TOPIC
THAT WILL HELP CALIFORNIANS AND
POLICYMAKERS AND ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE TIPPING POINT AND THEY ARE
GOOD USE OF THE STATE DATA OUT
A COUPLE THINGS TO POINT OUT OF
THE BILL DOES NOT JUST GIVE
ACTED TO ANYONE OUT THAT WAS
MENTIONED ON THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BLL MIRRORS THAT USED AND
OTHER SIMILAR SECTION FOUND IN
THE PENAL CODE. THAT PROVIDES
ACCESS ONLY TO BONAFIDE
RESEARCH BODIES- AND THAT
LANGUAGE HAS WORKED WELL FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FOR YEARS SECONDLY
RESEARCH BODY MUST BEAR THE
COST OF ANY DATA REQUEST
THEMSELVES SO THE BILL DOES NOT
INCREASE THE STATE COST- THANKS
FOR YOUR TIME AND I HOPE IN
EVERY JOB YEAH ABOUT. ON AB
FIFTY THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
THE MODERATOR NOW OPEN THE MAY
LINE FOR ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND I YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT MAY PRESS ONE THEN. ONE
NINE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI COMMITTEE
ON ALPHABET WITH UNITED WAY THE
CALIFORNIA IN SPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND ONE MOMENT FOR
ANOTHER LINE NUMBER. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE NOT FIFTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TERRY ONLY
WITH ECONOMIC SECURITY PROJECT
ACTION WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF ONE OF SIXTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
MADELINE JOHNSON. I'M WITH THE
EAST BAY HOW THE ORGANIZATION.
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND ONE MOMENT WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF ONE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS OUR
LAND AND SONOMA COUNTY
CALIFORNIA WITH HOMELESS ACTION
UNDER MY MATTE FORMERLY.
HOMELESS PERSON WHO IS VERY
GRATEFULLY HOUSE. AND I AND
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR CAN WE MAKE
SURE THAT THERE ARE CALLING FOR
A BI FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE. IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN. ZERO WE HAD GOT A
LINE OF ONE SEVENTY. THANK YOU
YES I'M IN SUPPORT OF THAT IT
IS STILL AS WELL AS THE
PREVIOUS ONE I DID I AM VERY IN
SUPPORT FOR THIS ONE AS WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO THERE ARE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. OKAY GREAT DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING CENTER GREAT
ANYONE IN THE ROOM DON'T COME
TO ME. ALL RIGHT THE MODERATOR
IF YOU CAN OPEN THE LINE FOR
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
Q. AND IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION. OF AB. FIFTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IN OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE
NO OPPOSITION TO IT THIS TIME
MANAGER GREET ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THE SEEING NINE ASSEMBLY RECORD
RIGHT I KNOW THAT YOU'RE TAKING
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS OUTLINED
IN THE COMEDIAN NOW SAYS I JUST
WANT TO BE SPECIFIED THESE
MOMENTS PROTECT IDENTITIES AND
PRIVATE THE DISCLOSURE OF
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION BY A
BONA FIDE RESEARCH COMPANY WITH
THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
ABSOLUTELY. DO WE HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND WE DID HAVE MOTION A
SECOND TIME SO SORRY AS I WAS A
GOOD CALL THE ROLL. AND TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE
HI BURKE ONLY WINNING. GREAT.
GRAY NOT LEARNING GRAYSON
GRAYSON ALRIGHT LEVINE WIENER I
CARRILLO REAL IRA MULLIN MULLIN
I PETRIE-NORRIS GENERAL ARTWORK
ALL RIGHT I RIVAS RIVAS I'D SAY
OUR TOE HI HERE TO A- GREAT NOT
LOADING TO OUR. THANK YOU CAN
TWO ZERO THE BILL THAT PASSED
THAT BILLS OUT- WE ARE JUST
WAITING FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO HIS HE- HEARD FROM HIM.
MANAGER WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO-
PERCENT THE BILL FOR SANTIAGO
IT'S THE ON IS WHERE YEAH. I
JUST. HI OKAY. SANTIAGO IS NOT
LISTED ON THE PORTFOLIO IS HIS.
DAVID. I'M NOT MORE HAVING
EITHER A TECHNICAL DIFFICULT
HERE IN ISSUE ONE MOMENT.
RIGHT.
RIGHT FILE ITEM THREE AB
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN. MOVE THE BELL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
NOW BE BRIEF ENTRANCE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I'LL SAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR OF YOUR WORKING
COMMITTEE WORK TO MAKE THIS A
BETTER BILL AND LET ME STATE
FOR THE RECORD THAT WE COMMIT
TO REMOVING A TAX CREDIT OR
STIMULUS PAYMENTS- LANGUAGE
WITHIN THE BILL IF IT'S NOT
RELEVANT TO THE BILL- PLANS AS
SHE TURNED BACK TO THE ASSEMBLY
THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU. AT YEAH
IT'S ALWAYS AGREED TO. YEAH
WELL LET ME MAKE SURE ON. YOUR
BILL GOT PULLED OFF OF THE
PORTFOLIOS WERE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT TO THE NUMBER
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WAS
THE PROBLEM. SO WHAT PART SEE
WHAT PART OF THE MOMENT YOU'RE
TAKING AGAIN SURE WHAT WE BUT I
THOUGHT WE COMMITTED TO WAS
REMOVING- TAX COURT OR STIMULUS
PAYMENTS- IN THE LANGUAGE IF
IT'S NO LONGER RELEVANT BY THE
TIME TO GET BACK TO- TO THE-
ASSEMBLY. IF THERE ARE ANY
OTHER FURTHER AMENDMENTS. IN
THINK IT WAS IF I THOUGHT YOU
WERE TAKING IT OUT AND THEN. WE
COULD CALL IT BACK. DAVID. IT
IS OKAY ARE GREAT THAT'S GREAT
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU YES SO THE-
OH GOD SO. DID YOU HAVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YOU ARE WE
DO WE HAVE A MINUTE- MEN FAN
FROM THE OC UNITED WAY
VOLUNTEER INCOME. TAX WHO-
ORGANIZATION HOSES AND THINKING
FIVE MY MASCOT STUFF THE SAKE
MODERATOR WHICH YOU OPEN THE L.
LINE FOR AT THE WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI- I MET MY
BUDGET I DO I HAVE TOO MANY TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF UNITED WAY
AUCTION EXCEEDED BOTH AND I
HAVE REPORTED PROJECT YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES BUT YOU HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND SO I WOULD
KEEP. I WOULD BE BRIEF. OKAY
THANK YOU. I'M A GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MANAGEMENT PLAN AND
ONE INSTRUMENT IN THE FIFTH
FIVE POINT EIGHT THERE WOULD BE
A PROBLEM. INCOME WITH THE
ORANGE COUNTY DO NOT. POSTED
FROM I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALLOWING ALLOWING TO
BE. RESPECTED YOU TODAY. AT THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN AND IT'S OF
A REFUGEE WHO DIDN'T. TO THE U.
S. TEN AND A HALF AGO. I
EXPERIENCED SO MANY OPTICAL I
THINK MIDDLE. ENGLISH AND HAVE
A DIFFICULTY TO COMMUNICATING
WITH AUTHORS. HOWEVER TO I'M
SEVERAL COMMUNITIES OF THE
STATE. PROGRAM I THOUGHT THAT
IN BEIJING WITHOUT COMMUNITY.
BY PROVIDING THAT LANGUAGE AND
PROVIDING THE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT TAX FILING
INFORMATION. AT THE NO COST
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I AM ONLY.
ABOUT AND I KNOW THAT I CAN
MAKE A REAL LIFE DIFFERENT.
SPOTS SO MANY COMEDY. SECONDLY
I'M HERE TO. MUCH WITH THE.
EIGHTEEN WE CAN MEET AND
HISPANIC COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY
FOR OUR LOW INCOME COMMITTEE
WHERE THEY NEED HELP I'M NOT
RELIABLE BY THAT. AND I DON'T
WANT TO SEE THEM BEING TOLD
AWAY FROM ABOUT THE PROJECT
BACK TO THE AND THE NUMBER OF
TAX PAYER THAT WORKS THANK YOU
SIR. 8443% I RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE
YES ON THE EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN SOCIAL OUT
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE YOU FIVE
O'CLOCK WORK AS MUCH AS THEY DO.
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU MODERATORS ARE
A ADDITIONAL. TESTIMONY IN SOME.
FOR AB. FIFTEEN FIFTEEN. THANK
YOU IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF ONE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MUST HAVE LIKE
OTHER WITH NIELSEN WORKS MARIN
BEHALF OF GRAYSON AND CHILD
POVERTY CALIFORNIA IS STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU X. OVER TO
LINE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR MEMBERS KATHY MUST
WORK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT OF OUR LINE OF ONE OF
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE
OF ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS KEVIN
ENDS FRIENDS COMMITTEE O
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I GET
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS THIS IS
ALEX SANCHEZ WITH THE
GOVERNMENT ORDER CENTER AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF ONE
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MANY MCCALL GREATLY
AND I AM AT THE CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE LIKE CALIFORNIA AND I'M
HERE TO. EAT FIFTEEN FIFTEEN.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF ONE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOE MEEKER FROM
THAT SENATE LEGAL SERVICES IN
LOS ANGELES WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AND GIVE
IT OUR STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE OF EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MELENDEZ AND
ON HOW THE PLAN WITH UNITED WAY
THE CALIFORNIA BONSER ASKING
FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY ON
EIGHTY FIFTEEN FIFTEEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MEXICO CAROLINA
ONE FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI TERRY ONLY WITH
ECONOMIC SECURITY PROJECT
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NEXT TO A LINE OF
ONE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS MARANDA
SHEFFIELD WITH THE WAREHOUSE
WORKER RESOURCE CENTER I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN. THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ENTER THANK
YOU ANYONE IN THE WITNESS
TESTIMONY VIDEO ROOM- SEEING NO
ONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
MODERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
PHONE LINE FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. GIVE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB. FIFTEEN FIFTEEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF
AB. FIFTEEN FIFTEEN. AND WE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME MANAGER. THANK YOU
ANYONE IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING CENTER NO- ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM SEEING
NINE- ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SEEING THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE GROUPS I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR STRICTLY ASCARI
BUILT. WITH THAT MISSILE WOULD
YOU CALL THE BOOK- I BELIEVE
THEY'RE DUTY EXCEPT THE TYPICAL
MOVIE YES IT. MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
BURKE HI BURKE ALL RIGHT WHEN
NOT VOTING GRAY. GREAT I
GRAYSON. GRAYSON I LIVING
FIFTEEN I CARILLO CREEL I
MULLIN. WELL IN THE EARLY
EIGHTEEN HOURS. ITCHINESS
ARTWORK HI. I REQUEST. THIS IS
SAID UP HAVE A FAIR NOT. NINETY
ZERO MA'AM NOW ZERO THAT UP
THOSE OUT I WILL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM ONE AB SEVENTY ONE. FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THE. I HAVE
THE VOTES ON SEVEN ONE- I NEED
NOT WHEN. ON FIFTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT SHE DOESN'T REMEMBER
VOTING ON SEVENTY. EXCUSE ME.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING ON WHICH.
ONE EIGHT. I HEARD YOU SAYING
ALL I READ THAT BACK. LET'S
JUST DO IT AGAIN FOR THE STATE
I'M WHEN. HOWEVER I HAVE YOU ON
FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT YES YES HI.
WHEN I. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE WE APPRECIATE WE
APPRECIATE. OKAY- THE FOLLOWING
IS AN ISLAND. OKAY WITH THAT WE
ARE CHEN.